just
one two three four five
thank you very much
wow
two minutes um members we'll start in a
couple of minutes thank you
good morning everybody welcome to
today's full council meeting
uh i'm just going to read out the
protocol for sort of buckland as it
as we're here again
no fire alarm is planned should the fire
alarm sound please leave the room and
meet by the stand at the far end of the
car park
please raise your hand if you wish to
speak and a boom microphone will be
brought over to you
if you don't speak into the microphone
you'll not be heard on the live stream
otherwise
uh please remain seated and keep the
points short as i ask members not to
repeat points that have already been
raised
voting will be by show of hands and
should the meeting be adjourned any
filming must cease unless the express
permission from those being filmed has
been obtained
during any adjournment i would ask that
members and
the public and officers please leave the
room until the meeting reconvenes
so we'll move to item one next please uh
sarah if you'd be kind enough to read
out the apologies for absence and go
from there councillor haines councillor
gordon hook councillor nuttall
councillor jenks councillor parker khan
councillor piet and councillor swain
thank you very much uh sarah for that
and as you see charles our chairman
uh isn't with us today hence you find me
in the chair
so that's the reason i'm here
uh right we moved to minutes item two is
minutes uh
i'm looking to uh propose aaron looking
towards the leader to propose the
minutes the last meeting is seconded by
the deputy leader alistair councillor
has to do hers
can i have a show of hands please that
the minutes are agreed
are there anybody against that
any abstentions to the minutes
there's three abstentions thank you very
much that's noted
so
that's but
four abstentions i beg your pardon i
didn't see the fourth hand
right so the minutes are approved thank
you very much
now we move to item three announcements
uh
right announcements uh
the six weeks
major makeover of the award-winning
children play area at the den in timothy
has been completed on schedule in time
for the school summer holidays and
incorporates a range of new equipment
and facilities and many of the features
are accessible for children with sensory
physical or learning difficult
disabilities
refurbishment works are also underway at
the broad meadow sports centre following
an officer decision to use
113
384 pounds of s-106 money to provide
upgrades to the sports hall and the
first floor mezzanine studio the works
will be carried out of the back of the
roof replacement works to prevent
further disruption to the site
the sports hall
will be fitted with a new
multi-sport
sprung floor system
and the measuring studio will be
enlarged through the removal of
storerooms and we will be fitted with a
new sports floor covering
we anticipate the completion of works in
mid-august and we'll plan a
phased return to normal operation across
the site
as vice chair
i've attended quite a few events in the
absence of the chairman she's having a
holiday i
went to the raising of the
flag on armed forces day
at
cambridge house very nice
event
much of the falklands was talked about
as you can imagine at that event so that
went off very well the next uh event i
attended was lama's fair in exeter where
things got back to normal with a big
parade
a lot of ceremony and the public i think
enjoyed it very much there was a huge
fare on the green i put
in front of the cathedral there and it
was great to be part of it representing
team bridge
duly booted and suited like all the
dignitaries
the next event i attended
and i think it's a great credit
to the area
is the success of team bridge propellers
in their new premises of at great
western way of ford road
the manufacturing propellers for all
over the world
employing over 100
people down there in very nice offices
indeed
it's a self-grown company they've grown
steadily over the years
and the princess royal flew in and my
wife and i shook her hands on behalf of
team bridge and she said to me
something like i expect you've been here
many times
so obviously they've done their
background checks to make sure that i
was up to uh
to the mark so we'll leave it at that
but it was a wonderful occasion
uh she was presented with a small
bronze propeller her house must be full
of knickknacks and what have you
so that was good and finally and i've
just talked about it i attended i got
there with seconds to spare
because it was last minute i attended
the opening of the den play park
and we received a wonderful crowd who
were queuing up they all had to sign
declarations to allow their kids to be
photographed if they wanted or not and
there was a huge crowd that went into
the play park so this has gone down very
well and uh it's a credit to team bridge
this new refurbishment so that concludes
my uh
events that i've attended on behalf of
the council
uh i'll just finish by going on to say
we'll have a 10-minute comfort break
hopefully at around 11 20 and looks like
a lunch break at 12 45 if that's uh
required and we and we haven't finished
the meeting and now i hand over to uh
the leader alan collett
he's got an
announcement as well to make thank you
very much
uh thank you chairman uh just two
announcements one in relation to virtual
meetings colleagues may recall i was
requested by council to write to
secretary of state michael gove on the
issue of the ability of local
councillors to continue with virtual
meetings i have received a reply from
kenny baden-knock mp minister's minister
of state well at the time of the reply
and have asked that the reply is public
i have asked that the reply is published
in the members newsletter this week but
in essence uh the reply says the
government is now considering responses
to its call for evidence which closed on
the 17th of june
2021. um and the next matter is in
relation to the cost of living crisis
and obviously the cost of living crisis
affects people probably everyone in team
bridge i've asked that uh councillor
martin wrigley to lead on the council's
response and have amended his executive
role to homes communities and cost of
living councillor wrigley will lead on
marshalling the council's current
support work with the voluntary sector
and others to see what more can be done
to assist and support residents chairman
thank you
thank you very much alan so that
concludes um
item three announcements we move on to
uh
item four declarations of uh interest
now just remind members to consider any
interest they may have and they if they
wish to discuss any interest they've had
with the monitoring officer we can have
a very short agenda uh adjournment for
that to happen so let's see how it goes
declaration of interest if you'd like
put your hands up thank you
councillor and patch
thank you
thank you chair i have three
declarations of interest of relevance to
items on the agenda today
the first concerns the fact that i am at
the moment preparing a claim in the
european court of human rights
regarding events in the standards um
case uh fiasco that i've been subjected
to um that i'd i raised this as an
interest
since this is something that might well
have significant financial consequences
for this council
secondly i should declare the fact that
this morning
i sent a complaint to devlin cornwell
police
regarding ongoing systematic and
coordinated misconduct in public office
and conspiracy to conduct misconduct in
public office by parties at this council
in association with my standards case
thirdly
i would like to report that i'd like to
declare an interest i've set up a public
information
facebook page team bridge rotten borough
for members of this community who would
like to gain an insight into the
workings of this council certainly over
the last two years thank you
i'm not sure there are actually
declarations of interest but you have
made your point thank you
thank you yes i'd uh i'd like to declare
an interest for uh one of the notices of
motion that comes forward uh
later that i'm uh now a
founding member of a community benefit
society that's
been registered by the financial conduct
authority called the alexandria theater
newton abbott
which is a charitable community benefit
society i don't propose to take any uh
remuneration from the uh society and uh
and none of my children are in business
with people who stand to earn millions
of pounds out of
out of uh any decisions that are made
relating to the theater so i do propose
to engage
but i thought it was only proper for me
to declare that interest thank you
thank you very much councillor richard
dawes are there any other declarations
of interest
whoops right we can move on to the next
item on the agenda
which is going to be easy
because it's item 5 public questions
there are none
so that makes that pretty easy doesn't
it so we move straight away then to
item six which is the shared
prosperity fund
all right the
executive member for economy and jobs uh
is going to propose this uh
um item so uh over to that person which
is
uh nina
counselor councillor nina jeffrey
thank you chair
good morning everyone i'm seeking
approval of the recommended
interventions set out in section 3 of
the report
the uk shared prosperity fund is a
successor to the eu structural fund
established to build pride in places and
increase life chances across the uk
1.64 million has been allocated to team
bridge to be spent by march 2025.
we need to submit an investment plan by
the first of august which is next monday
the main themes of the plan need to be
supporting local business community in
place
people and skills and the expenditure on
which is only due for 2024 and 2025
since the fund was announced in spring
officers have been working with other
local authorities businesses community
representatives and service providers to
draw up the recommended interventions
that are presented in today's report
this included various stakeholder
workshops held over the past couple of
months
a councillor oversight group was
established composed of the executive
member for homes and communities the
executive member for corporate services
and the two overview and scrutiny
committee chairs
the key interventions that have been
considered are laid out in appendices
one and two with illustrative costs
section three of the report summarises
the recommended
interventions
which are a green business grant backed
by independent carbon assessment advice
a program of education and advice
focused on preventing violence against
women and young girls
business support and training focused on
promoting clean growth and diversity
across our business community
promoting promotion of our town centre
outdoor markets and travel to our
centers
grants supporting wider participation in
the arts
whilst the five main area areas of focus
have been identified the manner in which
individual projects and grant schemes
will operate and who will deliver them
has yet to be designed and procured
engagement and community will underpin
these proposals
once the investment plan has been
submitted officers will undertake
further work on the scheme development
and briefs for support from expert
advisors
in consultation with myself and the
executive member for homes and
communities
so that they're ready to be implemented
when the investment plan is approved
colleagues will note that several worthy
interventions have not been recommended
for inclusion in the investment plan the
rationale for this links to there being
limited funds available and being
mindful that the council have limited
resources
these projects include the coastal
contribution which the councillor
oversight group felt might be difficult
to explain to government and could have
have civic significant resource
implications
it's recommended to delegate authority
to the head of place and commercial
services in consultation with myself and
councillor wrigley as the executive
member for homes and communities to
submit an investment plan to government
that reflects the recommended priorities
and then go on to implement that plan
the government is expected to make
decisions on whether investment plans
are approved by october this year and
says it will support local authorities
where further work is needed before the
investment plan can be approved
it is hoped that won't be necessary and
we'll be able to move our priority
interventions forward without delay
i'd like to thank our officer
group and colleagues for their work on
this proposal today which seeks to
address the economic needs but also
recognises the importance of arts and
culture to our team bridge communities
thank you
thank you for that is somebody going to
second it at this stage and before the
debate i'll second it your second year
thank you very much
yeah we'll come to you now we'll come
come to you now oh thank you very much
um
yes so um this is a comment for the
except member libdem um counselor
jeffries about violence
um and the urgent need
to address violence in our community
does she think that the council and this
lib dem leadership should get its own
house in order and make a clear
declaration of zero tolerance to acts of
physical aggression in the chamber
and i refer of course to the events of
september the 20th 2021 which led to
councillor gary taylor being found by
the lib dems to have brought the party
in to distribute his party by his
physical actions towards councillor
malone we have to lead from the front
we cannot expect our communities to
reject violence if we fail to do so in
this actual room
thank you
and who would you like to direct that
out
do you portfolio holder
over to you nina if you'd like to
respond or
thank you
um i understand that was a comment but
uh as far as i'm aware the information
that's in this report is for the whole
council to agree what the best
priorities are to take forward and
that's come out of the the community's
needs
and not necessarily what happens in
council
but that's not an answer to my question
it's about leaders in the front
to my question because it's about
leading to the front and being clear
that we condemn we all in here condemn
acts of physical violence in this
chamber and that hasn't happened
yeah
the solicitors just whispered to me what
i suspected i don't quite see what she's
got to do with the agenda item but
you've made your comment and
well
the reason why it's connected to this
agenda item is because we are the
leaders of our community and it's
important that we actually don't can't
get accused of hypocrisy you know if if
we're if we're condoning and even in
council connot's case going to the press
praising lots of physical uh
altercations then then we we need to
sort out our message i mean it's
ridiculous we've got to condemn violence
why is it so hard for us in here to say
we condemn acts of physical violence in
this very room why is that so hard i
condemn it anyone else want to
well councillor alan connect
is indicating to me he'd like to try and
answer your question so
we'll do we'll have him to speak if we
may thank you
alan
uh chairman thank you very much these
matters to which council eden refers
have been dealt with outside and inside
the council this is about the uk share
prosperity fund it's about investment in
team bridge it's about supporting our
communities i think actually our
comments need to focus on the business
in and
i'm not about other matters which can be
dealt with elsewhere thank you
i think i think in venice you've made
your point we'll leave it at that
okay so if we can move on to
this for a genuine debate on this item
before we vote on it i mean it it
it did i mean it did interest me as
chairman you know the report did here i
think it's only one in five here haven't
got a car in teams which it was very
interesting to you know to read these
reports and and see the information in
them
council mcgregor you'd like to speak
thank you chair um
a question for councillor jeff well
actually two questions for council
jeffries um council jeffries mentioned
that this was a replacement for an eu
fund
which obviously would have been formally
available before brexit
um is there any indication of
the level of funding compared to what
would have been available previously
under the eu
scheme
and also in terms of the
um actually no i'll forget the second
one just now if i could have an answer
to the first one that'd be great thank
you
martin councilman wrigley you're going
to try and answer that thank you chair
uh this is something i've been looking
into um i was asked the question
it would appear that
whilst many of the european funds are
difficult to to demonstrate across the
place
there was a fund that was paid to devon
for supporting businesses that was 120
million pounds over six years
which equates to about 50 million pounds
over a similar three-year period
but that was spread across
devon and
torbay
and somerset
when you add up the different districts
each one's getting about one or one
point four in our case one point yeah
one point four one point six million
it looks like it's about two-thirds or a
half there or thereabouts of what was
coming from europe so it is well under
the money that was coming directly from
europe let alone the other more
significant funds
and you just have to look at cornwall to
see that they're getting some like
one-tenth
um under these schemes as they were for
the european funds
right thank you very much if i may just
go on to having answered that question
whilst i'm talking if i can just say the
bits and pieces i think what we've done
is looked at
a number of different projects that came
forward which will benefit the area
now all of these have to be within a
very prescribed framework the government
lays out 32
individual interventions and everything
that you do has to be labeled as one of
these very specific things
so whilst it sounds quite good at the
top level that it's about communities in
place and supporting local business and
people and skills
when it comes down to it you are really
quite prescribed in what you can do so
we've tried to identify the areas where
we can really make a difference helping
small businesses
both in terms of their green growth in
terms of developing their skills and
actually learning how to grow their
businesses
is where the bulk of this money is going
to
but the other main area is supporting
open markets across the district helping
them work together creating a bigger set
of
providers and produce going into those
markets helping advertise those markets
and helping get people get to those
markets
as well as the other one which is
vitally important and we know the
cultural life of an area is key so a
significant investment in promoting and
building a
whole
program
of performances events exhibitions
across the district over three years
complementing what is already done
and helping kickstart in those areas
that don't already have significant
programs
more things for people to go to and see
so i think this is good news for team
bridge i think this is what the the best
use that we can make of this 1.6 million
and an agreement today will allow us to
put in the bid which has to be in with
typical government short time scales on
the first of august with a typical
longed government decision process to
have a decision in october this year
thank
you that outlines it pretty well martin
uh councillor phil willivan
sorry councilman i'll come to you next
thank you for the opportunity to
ask a question on this
excellent scheme that uh will be to the
advantage of all the people of
team bridge
as was said earlier as chair of one of
the
ons committees i sat with the group
looking at ideas and going through the
suggestions that came forward
at our last meeting about two weeks ago
it was suggested that
the
area being looked at here about support
for markets
would
justify talking to
newton albert community transport
association and i speak here as a
trustee of that organization
when it was suggested that a good idea
would be for um
someone to contact that organization to
understand the benefits they could offer
in terms of being able to bring into
towns
people from the communities
provide the sort of transport links that
we're currently commenting on their
inadequacies
and
support indoor markets
by bringing people into the towns
no such conversation has taken place and
i'm concerned that we're coming forward
with ideas
and i speak having attended a meeting
last friday when no communication had
taken place from the
member of the
council
and we're coming forward these ideas
without having the benefit of that
advice guidance and experience of groups
of people who can make a significant
contribution to how this fund should be
used so perhaps
like i have an answer as to why that
information was not sought thank you
alan the leader is going to respond to
that in a second but we have councilman
mcgregor first i haven't spotted that
thank you chair again um councillor
jefferies again um in in her uh report
mentioned the coastal contribution which
i recall was a fantastic initiative that
um
council jefferies put a lot of time and
effort into trying to develop and and
has stalled for various reasons over
over a period of time
um within the within her uh her uh
statement about the report she mentioned
that there would be some confusion over
the
coastal contribution but i would think
and hope
that this is still an option that the
council would consider for future
opportunities to have a separate funding
stream for communities across the
coastal path and i would i would hope
that council jeffries can confirm today
that she's as committed to that now as
she was when she first spent all that
time developing the idea
well she have a couple of minutes to
think about that before giving a
response
well we'll go straight to the leader
because i did say we go to the leader
first and then to council jefferies
thank you chairman in relation to the
point made by councillor bulovan i know
uh and he's declared his interest as a
trustee of the newton up at community
transport and i know some other
colleagues in the room or also trustees
would be interested um it's not correct
to say that we haven't been in
conversation we have actually i've had
a number of conversations with the
chairman of the new alberta community
transport association nigel cannon most
recently by email and telephone within
the past few weeks
the council is waiting for
newton albert community transport
association to prepare and submit its
proposals to extend its area in the
undercroft to the multi-story car park
uh officers uh met with um
members of newton albert community
transport i think maybe a year or so ago
so it's an ongoing piece of work and
regular conversations chairman so i'd
like to reassure counselors that very
much new and albert community transport
association have the ear of the council
and its senior officers and we await
their proposals thank you chairman
thank you alan for responding to that
right um very good right counselor nina
jeffrey
and thank you councillor mcgregor
your question about the coastal
contribution um yes we're very much
still committed to looking at that fund
um
the
shared prosperity fund priorities from
government um
it was about the more about the
explanation to government and whether it
would fit with their priorities at the
moment
um
things may change it's not off the table
in terms of this as
priority projects
and we are still working on the coastal
contribution behind the scenes
thank you
we've got councillor linda pedreck at
the back right at the back
and then we come to phil bulovan council
phil balon after that
okay
um
i understand why we're talking to newton
abbott community transport but can i ask
why we've not involved dualish community
transport who provides community
transport all over team bridge
i think we can answer that allen answer
straight off
thank you the straightforward answer is
that initially it was newton albert
community transport who approached us to
see whether they could stand extend into
the undercroft i've not had an approach
from the other community transport
association but i'm more than happy to
meet with them and discuss chairman uh
but at the moment i've not had an
approach from them but more than happy
to thank you
i've almost lost with the number of
people that are speaking so as
councillor david was coxed in a minute
we'd go to phil bullivan i think he had
his hand up first so put your hand up
phil so he can bring you a microphone
thank you i'm very grateful for the
leader for his as usual very accurate
and very detailed response that doesn't
answer the question the question is the
committee asked for a specific
discussion to take place
about this issue nothing about the
undercroft development which yes is
ongoing
and it's the fact that no discussion
took place
to ask the community associations what
support and service they could provide
thank you
so it's to councillor mcgregor next i
think it was here
who was after that
thank you chair again um i think from my
perspective uh listening to the the
exchanges going going through and
clearly um
we've got the leader who's suggesting
that the conversations were made and
we've got uh the leader of the
conservative group saying that it wasn't
um
if
the discussions have taken place
i would have thought for convenience
sake those discussions would have been
included in the explanation for the
report or perhaps in the members
newsletter prior to the the full council
meeting so i think there's a little bit
of a failure there but equally on the
side of the the a member of that
particular committee
to bring it up at this particular
meeting when they've had opportunities
to raise this over a period of time
is a little bit baffling as well
my my question would be is
this report
seems uh to have quite a lot of very
very good suggestions and you know
you know i'd like to thank nina for the
the the content that's in there
um but in terms of um the periphery
stuff this is detailed that we are
missing and often it's the case that
we're asked to make decisions without
being provided the detail
and it's always seems to be
on a controlled basis through the
leadership and my problem with that is
that if we're going to be asked to make
a decision on this now why haven't we
got all the information that council
economic assures us has actually been uh
dealt with
thank you
well
you posed a bit of an in-depth image and
i'll come to allen in a minute to try
and answer that we have david council
david cox who's just going to say
he's team bridge
uh community transport known as dawlish
disability sometimes known as daughter's
dispute much of the
annoyance of tinmath
covers the eastern side of team bridge
for ring and ride and for community
transport and it has a built in the uh
the car park in
uh
dallas which was gifted by the district
council known as the tardis um so i'm
not sure they're going to want to move
to newton now but
uh thank you i i find myself uh agreeing
with councillor bulovan actually in in
in terms of the
the being a pattern here because uh the
the not engaging with the interested
parties is something that we've seen
time and time again uh it happened with
na3 it happened with the alexander
theater and it's happening again uh so i
think uh to do his duty as
a local authority um the uh the
executive need to need to fully engage
with the groups
uh as councilman mcgregor suggested if
they have done that then please evidence
it and and and show the uh the support
and uh and and the opinions that
maintain on board and then
and then we'll be able to make value
decisions based on what residents
actually need and what groups are
telling the council they actually need
thank you
right come back to councillor alan
connect if we may and just so you're
pre-warned fergus you drafted this
report so perhaps you could pull
some oil on troubled waters after the
leader has spoken thank you
thank you chairman um to clarify uh i
was trying to describe in response to
council bulletin's first question a very
good relationship there is between
council members me because i primarily
meet with mr cannon uh and council
officers regarding community transport
they set out some time ago their
ambition to extend services and in order
to do that needed more space that was
separate too and outside of the
conversation about the uk share
prosperity fund because obviously this
wasn't available at the time i'm trying
to describe to council uh and
councillors that the very good i think
relationship there is with the community
transport association and the desire on
the part of the council to support the
association to extend its services that
would be supportive of what is now
the uk share prosperity fund as
colleagues have mentioned it is working
to some government parameters and
government timetable um so
fort belvon is is right i have not had a
conservation a consequence conversation
subsequent to the meeting to which he
refers but isn't he indicated that there
have been no conversations with nabi
community transport that's not the case
actually there's a very good
conversation being had we are waiting
for the community transport so exchange
to come back with their plans i'm very
supportive of the association would like
to see enhance and develop its services
in abba and i've said to councillor
linda patrick i'm more than happy to
meet uh the dallas based community
transport association as well to see
what their needs are and whether the
council may be able to assist i think
all of these things are things that the
council want and will want to achieve
chairman and now no no fergus pate will
be able to
inform the council regarding this
manchester which he is able to address
thank you
thank you leader and we'll go to fergus
at the back and
the officer that drafted this report and
in the light of the comments made by all
councillors fergus can you uh bring us
together
uh to a degree as best possible thank
you sure good morning uh thank you i'll
do my best and yes i did draft this
report and and yes meetings with the
councillor oversight group were held
officers were asked to make contact with
the various community transport groups
and uh and see what contribution they
might be able to make towards the uh the
intervention titled market and town
center promotion and coordination
as as councillor jeffrey said we've got
an opportunity over the summer once this
high level in
investment plan has been submitted to
work up the detail of the schemes that
we we might subsequently implement if
government approved the investment plan
in october
there was very limited time to put this
report together and my suggestion is
that we have those conversations and
discussions with other
partners that would go about
implementing the overall investment plan
before october so that we're ready to
roll when we hope to get the green light
uh yes thank you very much for that uh
intervention
in other words
you're saying there's more to come i
think underneath it all so is there any
more debate from all the members or can
we move to the uh the vote on this
please we've got a proposal in secondary
it was um
nina and martin wrigley with the
proposal so it's a name vote sarah
there's no no we can show it
we can do this by show of hands so all
those in favor please show
yeah i'm going to do thank you very much
those against
and those abstaining
four so it's carried thank you very much
good debate and
we move on to the next item
uh
this is the item seven
community governance reviews for ogwell
um
coffinsworld and edford parishes
um the leader is uh gonna talk on this
and propose it i think they're from what
i read
adding people to the parish council so
it shouldn't be too hopefully not too
contentious for us here at team bridge
leader
thank you chairman colleagues the report
is self-explanatory uh sets out the
detail and the proposals and i move the
recommendations i set out and invite a
seconder
councillor mary kolkaff's second did it
thank you mary yeah if you'd like
thank you uh as all members she wants to
speak yes
as one member for obwell
um i would like to give my support her
to the boundary changes particularly in
aguel
these are due in my opinion long overdue
um
for example uh with lark midway in
aguero one side of the road he's in
newton while across the road is in
inaugural
so this is most confusing for the
residents there
um
and as you will note that all all the uh
all the due consideration all members of
the public supported these boundaries
changes so i'm very happy to second the
proposal
you you were indicating you wished a
second i think mary beat you to it in my
eyes does that cause you a problem
no okay you'll speak alastair
thank you
lovely thank you chair um yes
i i would like to speak in support of
coffins well
i represent them on the county councils
they're a fantastic hard-working parish
council but only have five members
and it would really really help the
parish council to be able to have
another member so i completely support
this thank you chair
leader anybody no you didn't want it is
there anybody else that like to speak on
this
we can go to the voter i think this is
one we can put to bed fairly quickly so
uh
as we've got a proposal in a second can
we go to the vote please all those in
favor of of this motion
thank you
all those against
any abstentions
you oh there's one abstention counseling
alone
all right
turn the mic off we move on to item
eight which is the carbon action plan
uh
the
uh it's a long report pages 45 to 128
the executive member for climate change
council coastal protection and flooding
council jackie hook will
speak on this for us please and
introduce this thank you
thank you chair
i intend to give a brief introduction to
the plan the report and the plan then
i'm going to pass over to neil blaney
who'll talk us through a bit more detail
on the plan
so i really welcome the production of
part one of our carbon action plan
this plan looks at the carbon emissions
of the council as an organization
part two of a carbon action plan will
look at the carbon emissions of the
district as a whole
i wanted to take this opportunity to
thank will elliot our climate change
officer for the immense amount of work
he's put into this document and you can
see how long it is
i know as well that work on this plan
has involved officers from across the
council and i want to thank them too
hopefully you've all had a chance to
look at it and we'll be able to see that
it is comprehensive in what it covers
with policies targets and actions
corresponding to the council's main
emissions areas
in some cases the plan is leading the
way amongst other councils for example
in terms of its policy on embodied
carbon
and it is also honest and deliverable
wanting to truly reflect the totality of
the council's carbon emissions and lay
out plans for how we might tackle them
i'm keen that this plan is seen as a
living document it must be able to adapt
to changing circumstances
and to change to reflect scrutiny by
others
including our community partners action
on climate in team bridge
and by members town and parish councils
indeed anyone that would seek to comment
on or challenge it
i believe there is scope for immediate
scrutiny
personally i would like to see
additional work done on how we could
locally raise funds to speed up delivery
of the actions in this plan
and to build on the ambition of the plan
just one example and potentially there
are others are community municipal bonds
some councils have specifically called
them climate bonds and at least two
councils i know of of have raised one
million pound from within their
communities within a matter of months
if we can raise this scale of finance
and more from funding bids then we can
really begin to motor or maybe that
should be pedal
at the speed with which we will need to
so this is a detailed plan and we would
like to hear your comments
and i would welcome scrutiny by members
and others including action on climate
in team bridge via the scrutiny process
in the meantime i would recommend as set
out that we approve this plan
there is work still to do for example on
carbon offsets funding opportunities and
our scope 3 emissions
but this plan will better enable us to
put in funding bids that we want to get
on with this autumn
so we must not delay in approving the
plan and using its approval to
strengthen our hand in putting in
successful funding applications
but we genuinely welcome scrutiny and
comment and accept that this plan may
need to come back to full council
maybe soon and maybe several times going
forwards to update its policies actions
and targets
we don't have time to lose now even
climate scientists are shocked at the
pace of temperature rises
we are surely realizing now that climate
change will affect our day-to-day lives
our health our work patterns our
environment our infrastructure and our
economy
and the life chances of ourselves our
children and grandchildren
so i welcome this plan and recommend
that we approve it today let us get on
with implementing it whilst recognizing
it is a living document needing scrutiny
the microphone that we now go to
yeah neil blamed the officer
yeah
thank you chair i'll be brief so the
members can obviously start the debate
on this matter um it's just a bit of
background and the next steps
and summarize what members are
considering for today so at full council
on the 18th of april 2019 a notice of
motion was presented and debated calling
on the council to take action to achieve
a carbon neutral district the plan
before you today contains the targets
policies and actions to guide and
continue our path to net zero emissions
the carbon action plan will be made up
of two parts
the part one carbon action plan before
you today covers actions that the
district council can take to reduce
carbon emissions in our own immediate
financial control
the par 2 carbon action plan will look
at the whole district of team bridge
including but not limited to homes
businesses and transport
the devon carbon plan will be published
in draft during the autumn and our part
two plan will work in conjunction with
the wider devon plan
following adoption of the part one plan
officers will begin to develop the part
two plan and this will be presented to
members during the early part of 2023
the part one planned before you today
contains actions and targets which will
be subject to the development of
business cases and applications for
funding
that will further decarbonize broad
measure sports centre
it will include a review of our vehicle
fleet and will continue to improve our
energy efficiency program
each of these work streams alongside our
carbon footprint and work will feed into
the carbon budget review contained in
section 12 of the plot one plan
at the time of writing few local
authorities in devon have adopted
organizational carbon budgets
the part one plan intends to front load
the delivery of carbon reduction
projects to minimise long-term emission
accumulations
where we can and subject to business
cases we will aim to outperform the
carbon budgets
section 13 of the plan sets out how
members of the council will be able to
scrutinize the plan going forward and
the progress that it made towards the
targets
an annual review will take place to
identify new funding opportunities and
consider any national legislative
changes that impact on the plan
by approving this plan members will set
the next steps to continue reduction of
carbon emissions and finally it's also
important to recognize the significant
projects that the officers are already
working on to reduce our reliance on
fossil fuels across the three leisure
site projects in the work at fordhause
we will achieve a 23 reduction on our
carbon footprint thank you
thank you now go to hugh cox please
who's next to speak
thank you um
is that working
totally
is
totally agree with jackie on this um it
is a living document it does need
scrutiny going forward i'm more than
happy to go to go to my committee ons
one
as soon as possible and continue that
throughout the process thank you very
much
now the councillor phil bulovant please
are there any others any other speakers
thank you
can i thank and congratulate the
officers on being able to put together a
document of such detail and
important information
it's vital that this council has a plan
as we move forward we all make these
commitments to deliver the sort of
savings that we need to protect the
environment for our children and
grandchildren future generations
it's essential that we have this sort of
plan at our fingertips to be able to
refer to and apply in appropriate cases
it will always be the case where as
technology moves forward alternatives
come along and we need to be in a
position
to be able to adapt
and adopt alternative solutions to
deliver
the same or better results as we
as time goes by
for that reason i welcome the
opportunity to have this as a a living
document a document and a process that
will be open for review
for review
and come before this committee or this
before this council on a number of
occasions to make sure that it's always
up to date and we're delivering those
essential things that this document
seeks to deliver
so again congratulations to the team
that put this together and thank you for
jackie for bringing this uh before the
council for uh ratification
council richard dawes
thank you
i'd uh i'd normally applaud
uh steps in in in this direction
uh however in this instance uh i'd just
like to note that uh i don't think this
goes far enough uh and i don't think the
council uh as a body um
actions
uh the the uh
the issues around climate change uh as
as it should do we are living in an
emergency i mean the house is on fire
the country's on fire uh it was we saw
that last week and um and and there are
various uh various contradictions in in
what he said and what he's done uh
looking at the local plan we we're just
blindly moving forward and not
trying to even challenge
the conventional wisdom that we should
be building on open farmland
with all that issues all the issues
around that
and then
closer to home our own projects that we
are in control of and we can't blame
someone else for uh the the car crash of
a project that is ford house that uh
the the the
the insanity of of trying to retrofit
that building is something that should
either uh
been vacated by ourselves and and
allocated as a project to create social
housing
or or that should be the site where
developers are building houses um and
and we should be we should be we should
be taking our business to to uh buckland
fc to the alexandra theater to to to
other other uh venues uh around uh maybe
even we could get a dollish wouldn't
that be nice uh that uh the i think the
the costs the the yet to be determined
costs on fordhausen and the the impacts
that that will have in the in the long
term uh something that that will be
haunting as i think as a council thank
you
are there any other uh speakers uh you
want to sum up jackie now
if you so wish thank you i just wanted
to uh thank william elliott the the
officer
for the
fantastic detailed report that he's
produced
i note that um with the length of the
report and the time that is taken some
of the some of the material that's in
there has actually been completed
already so you know that there is a
massive
improvement in the carbon footprint of
the council as it stands at the moment
um in in terms of what i've heard
from some of the contributors um my
understanding is this this is for the
council to approve now
uh and the work as it will done will be
reviewed by scrutiny afterwards so that
will be that will be a positive step
that we're actually progressing that now
i note council obulovan's point about we
have to do
more um which is very strange from a
councillor who wanted to remove sill
which contributes to the environmental
mitigation
of the council's efforts
um
and
excuse me council blumen i'm making my
my secondary speech
we've had this discussion both in the
press and in council already so
i think you don't need to make a point
of order
from the perspective of going forward
council doors make some really
interesting points as well
yeah we do need to work harder at this
we do need to make make sure that we are
building the right
um developments in the right places
with the right mitigations otherwise
we're going to be watching those houses
burn like the houses in london did
recently
thank you chair
i don't think it was a point of order
there but i will allow you to respond
thank you i really
we're proud of this council
we try and represent the people of team
bridge
and we do it
in 46 47 cases around this room
with the best will and intentions
trying to
put forward a message which is both
factually incorrect and deformatory i
find objectionable
and i would ask the council that made
those remarks to remove them because he
knows they're basically untrue thank you
is there any other debate before i go to
jackie uh i would like to just
have a second
to hear myself i did study this report
very very closely
and uh
how can i put it
this is what is always interested in me
being a yachtsman and somebody that's
live right close to the water the report
said
to do with sea level rise there's uh far
less sea level rise in the north and
more in the south and by 2099 the rise
will be somewhere between 0.4 of a meter
to 1.2 of a meter which in old-fashioned
terms is
one foot four to four foot
so
i don't think anybody knows what was
happening but i would say
that in the past i'm 75 in the past 65
years that i've been alive
i've lived in a house that has been
so-called
subject to threat from floods it's one
of the most low-lying properties and i
can assure you that in those 65 years
sea levels are actually getting lower
and i can prove that with the evidence
that i've got
so i don't know where the tides are
suddenly going to jump up in the air
from and i hear all this alarming talk
coming from the ea that the whole of
newton abbott abbott's going to be under
water in in so well not the whole event
a good match of newton now it's going to
be underwater by
2099
well in that case i should have moved
from my property
years ago because i i'll be completely
over water we're not even a safe refuge
upstairs to go to so i'm not sure about
the sea level rise element i accept that
there's climate change
uh and i accept there's more storms than
ever and all that sort of thing i'm not
disputing that but don't let them tell
you there's an alarmist talk of sea
level rise at the moment here in this
neck of the woods there certainly isn't
thank you
counselor
i've i've had my little say which as
chair for for once and uh i'll go back
to the impartiality of the meeting
councillor dawes yes i'm not sure i'm
going to be totally impartial to be
honest but uh
i'd know council bulletin's point of uh
being proud of this council i i i sit on
this council i'm not i'm not proud of it
i'm quite ashamed of that actually in
many ways uh and i'm ashamed of
what's just being said by the chair as
well because that that's anecdotal uh
claptrap it's similar to the
the uh the front page of the daily mail
the day before the heat uh hit the
country uh suggesting that we were
a country of snowflakes and that nothing
was going to happen the next day of
course the country was on fire i i
suggest uh
we we don't do uh like pre-brexit and
say we've had enough of experts perhaps
we should start listening to the experts
and and not making it up as we go along
you you've certainly the right to
criticize me and i have the right to an
opinion as well so we beg to differ but
we and we better differ respectfully
which is what it councilwork i believe
is all about thank you very much thank
you richard
[Music]
jackie
thank you chair um yeah just to
summarize um thank you for your support
for the
carbon action plan part one
and thank you for the
commitment to
scrutiny of course
you've got the opportunity to do ongoing
scrutiny um as spell in out in the plan
as well through my six monthly
or whoever it might be six monthly
update um
to council
and scrutiny group you know feel free to
um interrogate and scrutinize there as
well that's your opportunity um
in terms of some of the points made
our local plan
i would say our draft local plan as it
sits at the moment is ambitious in terms
of what it's striving to achieve in
terms of net zero within the
the constraints that we're under of
course and we don't need to go over
government house building targets um
you know we we are pushing as far as we
can whether our draft local plan
survives government viability testing is
another matter but i believe we're
striving to do the best we possibly can
um
dare i even mention the forward house
issue perhaps we could go to will when i
finished just to go um on the on his
summary of the fordhaus project but
i think i've heard
councillor dawes suggest before that we
build housing on the front lawn of
fordhaus we need to remember it's a
grade one listed building
um
in terms of our own construction
projects that's why the policy in this
plan on embodied carbon which i i
believe is truly leading the way i don't
know that there's another council with
such a policy is looking at the lifetime
emissions of construction and
infrastructure projects so
where construction materials come from
their own carbon footprint transporting
them constructing the project even
looking at
what you do with materials afterwards
should you demolish the building or
recycle it or reuse it
so and the maintenance of the building
as well the full carbon
footprint of the life time of a building
um so
you know we have got ambitious policies
in here but in terms of um
whether we can improve on that yes i
believe we can improve on it i've
already mentioned personally i feel we
could be
achieve more and achieve it more quickly
if we look at funding opportunities and
and to me there is a a missing section
that could we could look at um
how we can raise more funds to achieve
the plan quicker
um so in that sense i do agree with that
but i as i say we need to approve this
plan now we're planning to put in
funding bids this autumn and this plan
will really help us um do that and i
look forward to further scrutiny thank
you
there's councillor adrian patch and then
we'll go to
the climate officer
didn't you want
the climate change officer will elliot
to speak
yeah i thought you did okay thank you
chair
um yes i i just found it interesting to
hear the the listing status of of the um
carry on yeah interesting to hear the
listing status of old ford has cited as
a barrier to development um i'm just
with with the view to an upcoming item
on the agenda can anybody remind me if
the alexander theatre is listed and if
so what the grade is of that
two okay but it is a listed building i
believe
okay thank you
okay well we'll go to um climate change
officer willow
because jackie did sum up uh there and i
allowed aid councillor adrian plaques to
just come up with that so uh we'll
earlier
at the back
hello good good morning everyone
i just simply like to say i'm pleased to
present the carbon action plan to you
today um i hope that you agree that it
contains a number of positive plans
um that will benefit the local authority
and our residents
and i will look forward to getting to
work on the targets actions and policies
contained within the plan
um including an energy efficiency
program the development of a business
case to further decarbonize broadband
sports center
supporting our partners through the dev
and energy collectivity to decarbonize
our electricity supply
the development of the depot master plan
to look at ways that we can decarbonize
our vehicle fleet
to engage our suppliers are working
towards decarbonizing our
house scope 3 indirect carbon footprint
and perhaps most
most importantly of all
to limit
the cumulative amount of emissions that
we produce
and to limit our overall um contribution
to global warming
thank you right let's go to the vote
then uh everybody um those in favor of
it we had a proposal in second so let's
go to the vote
thank you very much those against it
those abstaining
one
thank you
thank you for all your work uh
councillor hook if i may say so
a lot of pages there weren't there no
as well isn't it well
okay
next item uh is revision to the uh
constitution
uh which the executive member for
corporate services councillor keeling
will introduce uh richard if you'd like
to introduce item nine
thank you very much mr chairman um
revision of paragraph 4.26
of the constitution the review has been
undertaken following notification from
hm land registry regarding changes to
land registration procedures and
requirements this in simple terms allows
the council to do its work more swiftly
i therefore propose as set out the head
of legal service paul woodhead is here
also to answer any further questions
thank you mr chairman
seconded by councillor alan connect i'm
throwing it open for the debate
those that want to speak on it
it seems fairly straightforward this
it's about the
the seal being put on uh
things uh because there's a bit of
ambiguity which paul might care to
outline a little bit but counselor
mcgregor you wanted to speak so over to
you thank you chair it was just really
again it's um trying to get the
information prior to the meeting so that
um councillors can have
full information about justifications
reasoning and
impact and an impact assessment so that
we understand what the implications are
beyond the actual vote
and i i would hope that perhaps having
repeated this a couple of times recently
previous meeting and in this one that we
will start to see more detail coming
through so that uh councillors are
actually fully informed for decision
making purposes thank you
well actually i thought the detail was
fairly good alan the leader wants to
speak
next and before i hand to paul woodhead
allen leader
thank you chairman um
this was one of the number of proposals
contained in uh
draft or proposed amendments to the
council's constitution which went to the
last procedures committee
that committee
deferred all decisions uh so that groups
could discuss the range of proposals and
then come back at a later date so there
will be full consultation on them this
was the one item where the header legal
services uh paul wood had asked the
council to make a decision so that it
was compliant and able to take advantage
as uh councillor keeling pointed out so
it's all there and it's all there in
detail and some of that was explained in
more detail at the procedures committee
so i reject council mcgregor's
commentary with regard to the points he
made i think it is there it is clear and
it is here now for members discussion
thank you chairman
uh yes indeed i concur with your views
on but i would like paul woodhead to
speak on this because i think the seal
needed to go on some documents and i
think he's now in charge of the seal but
he'll tell us more i'm sure
thank you i'm not quite sure why what
there is to add to um what's already
been said and what's in the in the
report but
but the the reality is that we we could
continue as is but but to continue as is
would become an administrative
bureaucracy gone mad to comply with land
registry requirements hence the report
and the alterations to the existing
wording
in the um constitution
and i've highlighted obviously as
members can see in the report by way of
track changes what those what those
changes are and we've just pretty much
emboldened um aspects of the current
procedure um there are no fundamental
changes it's just that we've we've set
out more more particularly
the the process that we will follow from
now on and that and the resolution of
this council should it decide to
uh all those against
any abstentions
that was carried we did note the four
abstentions thank you very much
microphone again
move now to item 10
appointment of the independent persons
and we're going to ask once again
the executive member for corporate
services councillor richie
keeling to introduce
item 10
yeah if we can thank you thank you mr
chairman
appointments of independent persons
due to the resignation of two
independent persons of this council we
recommend that devon county council two
independent persons be appointed on an
interim basis i therefore propose that
the council appoint ian brooking and ted
butt to serve as independent persons for
interim period of no more than six
months
the monitoring officer paul woodhead is
here to answer any further questions
thank you
i'm looking for a second please
i've got a question
yeah we come to that you're seconded by
councillor alastair duhas
right um
yes
um thank you very much yes um to explain
um the couple of questions that i've got
for for councillor keeling i just need
to put this in context very quickly um
at the last meeting i put a question
about diversity and disability to
councillor connet the lib dem leader
and uh i realized when i saw the
recording afterwards that off mike he
had accused me of and i quote faux
anger i had been talking about prejudice
and disability so that was rather
shocking to see so i hope that
counselor keeling will understand
my couple of questions on this on this
report so first of all
do these two men meet any of the
protected characteristics under the
equality act 2010 do they meet any
characteristics for diversity and
inclusion
secondly what provision for unconscious
bias training
has been made for these two men
thank you
my apologies counselor allison eden i
forgot to introduce you then uh the item
so the public didn't now know who was
speaking i'm quite happy to repeat the
question no no
i didn't
i i moved i moved to you and i didn't
say your name and i apologize for that
okay
who wants to respond
thank you mr chairman
yes
councillor keeling carry on
thank you mr chairman um i shall pass
your question on to the uh monitoring
officer council eden thank you
the monitoring officer paul woodhead
please
thank you um
the
two independent persons set out in the
the report that i'm i'm recommending are
appointed on an interim basis currently
as it says in the report
um occupy these posts
for devon county council
they are also
perform that function for one or two
other local authorities
they meet the statutory criteria
required of of the post
i'm unaware of whether either of them
have any protected characteristics
because
that is irrelevant they meet they they
meet the statutory criteria
should they have a protected
characteristic i think that's a personal
matter for them one of the reasons for
the interim appointment is so that we
can look at
how we recruit
suitable persons on the full-time basis
for the council
the
comments observations proposals made by
councillor eden previously to which have
been alluded to have merit
and will be considered and are being
considered as part of that permanent
recruiting process
thank you
i want to go to the council david cox
who indicated and there's uh i used to
be a director of plus the organization
that employs disabled people and people
who have um
characteristics effectively
under the uh the 1990 equality act um
the people there uh self-identified as
disabled
there were people there who in my
opinion obviously not in their opinion
were disabled but they didn't want to
want to be labeled disabled so it is a
gdpr issue if people have those
characteristics they shouldn't be
required to tell us that oh i'm a you
know i'm a muslim or i'm a i'm disabled
in some way well you know we should we
should follow the legislation and that's
what we we're doing i think we should we
should say when we advertise that we
would particularly welcome people from
uh
minorities disabled et cetera um because
they are underrepresented in at the
moment but to to start inquiring of
people
you know what is your you know
disability what is your characteristic
what is your sexuality you know i think
that's really not actually about
business it's can they do the job
a period
councillor patch was next to speak
thank you just just building on
councillor cox's point about can they do
the job and looking beyond the interim
appointment i wonder looking forward um
how confident we are that there's an
adequate competency framework in place
for that recruitment
um
and and i would suggest drawing on my
background in human resource research
and consultancy
that some
some in-depth thought and perhaps some
outside advice is given um in terms of
getting that competency framework right
and i speak having seen evidence within
the last um
last 12 months of someone who was
appointed an independent person
quite obviously not knowing the
difference between an elected
representative a councillor and an
appointed officer so i think that's
quite fundamental to carrying out the
role of independent person particularly
with regard to the important
sort of circumstances around standards
cases and investigations and the support
that might be offered so
the question is
are you confident that you're going to
have the right competency framework in
place when looking at the recruitment
beyond the interim appointment to get
the right people in place
people who can do their job
i'm going to come back on this to paul
woodhead
to answer thank you chair um the issue
of protected cash districts the the the
two individuals that will look that i'm
recommending we appoint an interim basis
were
interviewed spoken to
however you wanted to um reference that
and they were asked if they had any
particular
um
uh issues which would require
um
reasonable adjustments such like and
neither of them declared any um
but i as i say
beforehand
when i say irrelevant because what i'm
saying is that they wouldn't be
discounted
if they were to have any and that's the
point i was making because we we have to
comply with the statutory
uh requirements
in answer to council patches
issues and as i mentioned a few minutes
ago one of the reasons for looking to a
point on an interim basis is so that we
as a local authority can be clear and
sure that the very valid points raised
by a council you didn't which i've
previously referred to and those by
council patch
will be addressed so that when we go to
recruit and we act and we
uh go through the recruitment process
this council can be can be sure as sure
as it can be that we appoint
the right people for the post and the
function which will be asked of them to
perform
and that we are mindful
of
the need to
to reach out to all sections of society
regardless of what those sections are
um
and that
people are appointed purely on merit
thank you chair
thank you paul councillor andrew
mcgregor and then council liam malone
thank you chair um just a couple of
points that have come up i mean we're
actually not talking about the equality
act 1990 we're talking about the
equality act 2010
normal practices to ask the question but
include a prefer not to say or not or
don't know element into that so that's a
normal recruitment practice can speak on
that with some authority having worked
in recruitment for 20 plus years
uh also worked in welfare to work and a
little bit more recently than councillor
cox was working for plus
um and
would suggest that
people don't identify as disabled people
are either disabled because they are
diagnosed as such
on a wide range of issues um
in terms of the um independent persons
one of the
the points i've made a number of times
recently is lord evans of waredale's
2019 report which sets out exactly what
the criteria should be
when using an independent person i was
just going to ask an insurer that we
will adopt best practice as laid out in
his report
and lastly just just to clarify um
whether or not there's any personal
relationship or any professional
relationship between the independent
persons and any of the senior leadership
team including the monitoring officer
for this interim appointment it's just a
question
thank you
before we go to liam um paul would like
to respond the answer to councilman
mcgregor's question is no
and that specific question was asked of
the two individuals thank you
that clears that up counselor malone
um i would counter that the last two
independent persons we had were disabled
they were disabled by not knowing what
the job is or what they were doing in it
it is very very important that
independent persons do not
count out or defer to authority but are
in fact independent
understand the processes of the council
but can rise above it the uh resignation
letters of the last two people were
absolutely risible
they uh they just didn't understand what
they were supposed to be doing and they
were absolutely horrified that people
disagreed with this executive its
decisions and its prejudices uh so this
isn't a question it's just an odd hope
can we have some independent people who
a are independent and b have a brain
please
counselor richard dawes
uh just following on from that i'd uh
i'd
uh the the bit that made me worry uh
when it was just explained a second ago
is that the independent persons are
independent persons at devon county
council uh there's uh
there's a whistleblower within team
bridge district council which will soon
be a matter of public record who
suggested that the previous independent
persons who resigned were in the post so
long that they'd become
institutionalized
uh and therefore part of the
establishment uh so uh it it worries me
that that we're appointing an interim
that is uh uh
ostensibly a part of the uh
of
of the establishment so more of the same
are there any other speakers before we
move to the vote
you you can also honestly need you want
to just say something um just just
really wanted to pick up on the on the
training um my comment my question
rather about unconscious bias training
it's so important actually for all of us
and everything that we do and i i would
urge i would urge the monitoring officer
and the executive to really look at this
properly people in this room might think
they know what it means they might
people you'll often hear people saying
things like oh i'm not prejudiced you
know actually working in clinical trials
as i do knowing a great deal about undue
influence coercion you know knowing
about bias i i would urge urge urge
people to look into the really good
accredited
unconscious bias training for our
independent people it can't do anything
other than good so please look into that
thank you
thank you
right there's no other speakers so do we
move to the vote on this please again
those in favor of these two interim
people from devon county council
representatives please show those in
favor
thank you very much for those against
two
those abstaining
three
thank you very much that's karen thank
you so much
right we've got to 11 20 and i think
it's time as we said for a break for 10
minutes we've got uh 11 12 and 13 which
are motions coming forth uh with
counseling questions at the end so
hopefully we might get there by calling
the one we'll come back in 10 minutes
please just
if we can resume if we may please
[Music]
right thank you everybody for
getting back in the swing of the meeting
uh item 11 is the next one a
recommendation from the executive from
the 31st of may
uh notices a motion uh on bus routes and
i'm going to ask the executive members
for homes and communities councilor
martin rigger wrigley to introduce this
item thank you
don't think so what have i done wrong
um
thank you this is this is this is a
motion that came to full council a while
back brought to that council by council
allison foden
and standing up for the buses in the
area so the changes that we've seen to
bus provision in devon and the
government funds coming to devon for
buses is just deplorable
devon put in a plan asking for i think
it was 15 million i'll be corrected by
my fellow different councillors and they
got 1 million it's just not enough it
was 150 million they got 15.
i apologize i'm not doing my homework on
devon
so they had a minimal funding from the
government in terms of this bus back
better scheme meanwhile we're seeing
stagecoach cutting routes left right and
center and it's not good enough this
motion tries to do what we can to
address that
it came to exactly we had a full
discussion i'd like to hand over to
allison foden to have more comment on
this motion
my apologies if i did get that wrong
my briefing notes
have let the situation down
all right
anyway counselor
thank you to the executive for their
recommendation
so
bus travel is essential for the economy
of team bridge and devon
for our local communities and for our
well-being
especially so in this time of climate
crisis and the cost of living crisis
we need to call on devon county council
stagecoach and all the bus companies to
change their way of thinking
from the vicious circle of slower buses
fewer passengers fewer buses more cars
more congestion and pollution and more
cuts to services
to change the way of thinking to the
virtuous circle
of more buses more passengers
quicker buses less congestion
less pollution better for people and for
the planet
and to create a transport for devon
service that we can be proud of please
support this motion
thank you
well the outcome of the motion is that
the council asked the leader of this
council to write to devon county council
and stagecoach devon to declare this
notice of motion so do i have a proposal
is it going to be councillor
folden would you like to propose that
reduce getting the order right now and
you'll second it martin we all second it
so throw it open to debate now
councillor phil bulovin
thank you
at devon
county council yesterday there was
discussion taking place about the
inadequacies being of
affecting the
bus services throughout the whole of
devon and
devon county council writing to the
providers of the transport services to
complain
and arrange meetings the first which is
taking place on the 1st of august
it should be noted that
this view of the inadequacies is shared
by all counsellors and i certainly
endorse this as a motion in terms of
giving support to devon county council
in its actions to make sure that
services are improved
it doesn't help that stagecoach
notify
notified
us that
that's not me ringing by the way
thank you
devon county county fight notified us
that they'd received her information
from stagecoach that they'd allocated 29
of their bus drivers to go to birmingham
for the duration of the commonwealth
games which meant that services were
going to be contained within
devon to release those drivers
and obviously that caused a great deal
of upset at the county council so
anything that we as a council can do to
inform
or support the actions being taken by
devon county council i certainly endorse
and welcome and i certainly will be
happy to endorse this as a
recommendation thank you
thank you mr chairman and i thank
councillor alison foden for a valuable
work on this motion
i'm pleased to hear what the leader of
the conservative party is saying and and
support that
over the weekend i was contacted twice
once by a resident who works in spec
savers who
was warned about his lateness to work
is not his fault as the buses were late
on several occasions
and the second more importantly was a
lady resident returning from an extra
hospital appointment had to wait several
hours
as
two buses were cancelled
she also informed me that there's no
buses back from exeter to chudley after
6 pm
i'm also aware as uh
my fellow councillor for the team
valleys as well that the bus service has
been discontinued by the bus company and
i would however like to thank the newton
about community transport for stepping
up and helping those rural communities
i asked the simple question when is
devon county council and stagecoach
devon going to step up thank you mr
chairman
counselor janet bradford next to speak
thank you very much
thank you chair um i would really um
like to support this motion
residents are getting left at bus stops
all over the place um in newton albert
there was a young lady down by the
station
on a sunday evening with her seven
months old and her three-year-old
waiting for a bus that never came
um i i would really support this thank
you
as well it's uh do you want do you want
to come at the end alan yeah it's
councilman mcgregor now andrew
thank you chair um that there's a very
wide ranging set of issues here it's you
know
you know i note all the good comments
about individuals here and individuals
there uh struggling with with getting
transport
this county already has a problem with
rural loneliness
cutting back bus services um not just in
team bridge but across the whole county
uh stagecoach are increasing that rural
loneliness
uh one of the elements of the
discussions i had on the health and
wellbeing committee was that rural
loneliness leads to increased suicide
risk
so this this is really this isn't just
about whether or not people can get to
work this is actually about people's
whole life experience and whole life
impact and it's really really important
that not only devon county council but
team bridge write to the government and
say they need to ante up more funds
anyway
but we should be working with devon
county council to find ways
i mean what one of the the elements that
we discussed earlier uh councillor
hook's
carbon action plan
is to encourage more use of public
transport
we don't have a huge amount of roads
that are suitable for people to cycle up
and down
so it's either public transport or a car
so for us to sit here and say we've got
all this wish list without actually
really being quite forceful about it
is is a little bit depressing so i think
we really need to up our game be much
more demanding be shouting shouting
shouting all of the time both stagecoach
and other bus companies but also at the
sen at central government saying they
are putting people's lives at risk
that is the message that we need to get
out there and it's not a question of
because it's a conservative government
i'm saying this any government that puts
any council in this position where
services are cut
and it risks people's lives
needs to be notified of that and really
loudly
thank you chair
councillor alan connect we move to now
oh personal patch in a minute um do you
want council patch to go before your
eleanor
councillor alan
adrian patch
thank you chair i know that there are
quite a few um towns in here mentioned
in this motion
but no explicit mention of um
areas and rural isolation and speaking
of representing a rural award i'm aware
that there's um two buses i think one on
one on a tuesday and one on a friday
coming through my particular um ward um
i just wonder whether we can somehow
make um make an inclusion there for
rural
wards as it seems to be the worlding is
very
focused on
a number of towns and larger settlements
right removed to councillor alan connect
thank you adrian
thank you chairman and counselor patch
if you'd like to email me i'm happy to
incorporate your example into the letter
if council approves that emotion is uh
approves a motion i write the letter to
german county council and stagecoach i'm
more than happy to incorporate examples
in fact i uh without wanting to do a
long list from every member i mean if
there are some examples that members
want to uh
send to me i'm quite happy to include a
representative sample but certainly if
councillor patch emails me i'm happy to
incorporate it this did come up that
council last time was referred to
executive so i think one hope that
colleagues may may be able to contribute
to that but absolutely fine and
incorporate that now if i'm a chairman
uh councillor bulovan's point about
devon county council entirely agree i
think the county council i've seen a
copy of a letter from the uh lead
councillor responsible for this area of
work andrea davis who's written very
robustly to
a stagecoach about bus services and i
entirely endorse her letter in my own
area we're seeing changes to the b
service in ken and ken ford for example
as just you know two buses a day one in
and one out which isn't obviously as bad
as cancer patches described
and what i would say as well is the
council for protection of rural england
last year published a brilliant report
describing how it was quite possible
with some changes in the way that the
nation funds its bus services to secure
a bus every hour in every village
and i really would commend members to
read that i mean i read it and i thought
to myself you know that what we're
trying to achieve here is not
aspirational is about a change in the
way the nation thinks and uh the points
that council mcgregor makes about rural
isolation are all part of the intrinsic
need and necessity for a quality bus
service it's not just older people who
may be isolated but the 16 year old in a
rural community the difficulty for them
for example even getting to sixth film
college or maybe to their apprenticeship
so buses are brilliant and we should
celebrate them and i really do welcome
the motion that councilor foden uh put
forward and i i take from what
colleagues are saying across the chamber
uh that there is wide support for buses
in team bridge and we will do what we
can but primarily that is around devon
county council and if members will wish
me to i'm quite happy to extend so i
send a copy of the letter to the two
members of parliament for
serving team bridge
i would offer to write to the relevant
minister but i think we might want to
wait until perhaps later in the year
when it's more clear about which
minister will have longer-term
responsibility for public bus services
thank you chairman
thank you alan if you can add stoken
teen head to the list that would be
lovely send me the email channel i'll
send you an email right okay thank you
very much are there anybody else else
would like to speak on the item before i
ask for a show of hands
show hands then please to support the
motion
looks like being unanimous i think
thank you
okay yeah those against
those abstaining
unanimous
sarah thank you
thank you very much that's good
yes
now we can move to item 12 now
yeah
just before before we go i'd like to
raise the point of doing a personal
explanation on two of the items that
were discussed earlier
as in as a in accordance with the
constitution
uh if you're quicker i don't see why not
i was do you want them do you want them
to hear them now i think so okay the
first one
if you can keep it fairly brief yeah
well
the first one was uh in relation to
councillor jeffrey's uh report that came
in
um
in terms of the
questions that were asked myself and
several other counselors asked questions
directly of counselor jeffries
uh councillor jeffries was not given the
opportunity to respond the the responses
came without
deference to to counselor jeffrey's
presenting the report
and in a a show of patriarchal uh
element to the to the council and also
um
you know i i had to intervene
to stop a male conservative councillor
barracking
a female counselor who's raising a point
based around violence against women and
girls and i actually would like to
point out that that was the only reason
for my intervention i don't think it's
it's it's appropriate for male
counsellors to be barracking um
female counselors who are raising points
about domestic violence or potential
violence against anybody never mind
violence against women and girls the
second uh personal explanation
um
can i come back to that one after the
next motion because i've i need to have
a little think about how i want to
phrase that okay all right thank you
we're moving on to the next item uh
if we can then please
uh if we're now on to item 12 aren't we
uh recommendation of the executive
of the fourth of july this is a notice
of motion for the ocean and coastal
recovery declaration
and we go to the executive member for
climate change and coastal protection
and flooding
councillor jackie hooke
thank you chad
when i spoke at full council last on
this notice of motion i outlined how
very important our oceans are
that every second breath we take is
provided by the oceans
i refer to the ocean's influence on our
climate and the climate's influence on
our oceans
since then i've read probably as you
have recent reports about the dramatic
decline in plankton and ocean life in
general which of course is a major food
source for many in the world
and then when i spoke at executive i
talked about our rivers and the threats
they face
we know the health of our rivers is a
huge concern to our residents and i
reported that sadly southwest water has
become the latest water company to come
under an off-what investigation into the
suppliers environmental performance and
sewage treatment works
joining five other water companies
already under investigation
the regulator said
from what we have seen the scale of the
issue is shocking companies must resolve
any problems that wastewater treatment
works and do so quickly
within the last few days southwest water
have begun a consultation on their
wastewater management plan
and this will be something you may wish
to look at and comment on and scrutinize
i want to thank members for your support
for the actions contained in this notice
of motion
and it comes back today from executive
in the same form unauthored
here at team bridge we must play our
part in ensuring the health of our
rivers and oceans
we are doing good work already but we
must step up and coordinate and make
clear our responses to these issues
which is what this notice of motion aims
to do
the first set of recommendations outline
actions we as a council should take
including to write to southwest water to
request details of their urgent and
revised plans to eradicate the practice
of sewerage discharges to rivers and
coastal waters around team bridge
in addition the notice of motion asks
for us to report to full council within
six months on the actions and projects
that will begin in ocean recovery in
team bridge
and i wanted here to thank officers of
the council
specifically graham smith coastal
officer who i think is here today
for adding in actions to the notices of
motion to make sure we are addressing
all issues of concern
the second second section of
recommendations are demands of the
government with regards to minimizing
sewerage discharges to our waters
and a third section covers our demands
of government in relation to ensuring
the recovery of our oceans
this notice of motion is linked to the
council's declarations of both climate
and ecological emergencies but crucially
as we face tough economic times ahead it
seeks to focus on wider objectives of
ensuring a resilient and sustainable
economy and the health and well-being of
our residents
i hope members will support the notice
of motion thank you
secondly
alistair was first
you were giving notice to speak i think
over there weren't you
oh you wanted a second it well i
i apologize if that's the case i thought
you'd intentionally speak
you will be speaking all right well i
had you down to speak first of all all
right so yeah you best go ahead please
and speak thank you
thank you chair um
it's uh refreshing to see emotion coming
after
a considerable amount of pressure from
the chair
over the last
18 months myself and councillor cox
particularly over the sewage discharges
into the teen estuary
it's a particularly interesting um
motion in as much as it's broad-ranging
it covers lots and lots of uh various
aspects of the health of the the ocean
one of the the key elements to that of
course was the the huge debate over the
mmo dumping off the coast
um
so going all the way back to 2019 um you
know there's there's quite an element of
uh
work for us to do but also coming back
to 2019 as you know uh chair from from
our exchanges on on online
the environmental agency notified this
council that almost every single sewage
treatment station and
asset within team bridge district
was at risk
of being unable to cope with the
developments that were
being planned
that is um that is a comment that there
appears to be no action from and when
the planning exec was questioned about
various aspects of that it was always
it's somebody else's problem
going back over several meetings
from my perspective this is a
a motion that should have come two years
ago or maybe three years ago when this
was first highlighted through the
planning department the environmentally
environmental agencies concerns that
were raised about southwest waters
capacity issues
it was specifically in response to local
plans so that's stuff going forward not
historically
it's really important i think for us to
maintain pressure on southwest water
maintain our
pressure on the environmental agency to
um
or the environment agency to
develop a
communication system as i've raised on a
number of occasions off what's own
advice is regular
detailed ongoing meetings with the
planning authority
the utility provider and the environment
agency and we have failed spectacularly
in that respect so far and i think
there's an opportunity as part of this
motion to put that in place thank you
chair
uh next is
alistair jew jewhurst next to speak
thank you chair um i wanted to support
uh this motion
i think it's an absolutely vital motion
we have
supported and agreed motions in the past
on climate change
and the environment and this is the the
third part of that looking after our
oceans
if we agree this today it will put
our council in a small and select group
of councils uh that have
effectively passed this uh this motion
um although
in a number of important respects this
motion goes further than the general um
motion for the ocean that that is
out there at the moment
um so
for me i will definitely be supporting
it thank you
councillor
thank you mr chairman um i'd like to
thank councillor jay hook for this
motion
and
pointing out the effects to local
businesses
in my area we have the river teen
shellfish who serve our community
restaurants and export to the wider uk
and vitally important to local
employment so we need to address these
potential issues
in the team
which is pressurized on onto our local
businesses this motion achieves that
thank you mr chairman
thank you councillor richard cleaning
now it's councillor sylvia russell
another followed by david cox thank you
chairman um i i just asked the question
i used to be a member of um
an organization that
kept a watch on what the water company
was doing first of all it was under the
umbrella of wolf what and then it became
known as water voice and it was
representation from local government uh
health service etc we used to meet with
the water company just to keep up to
date with the improvements and you
remember the clean sweep here at
timothy was one of the big first of the
first operations that took place
is this is this organization water voice
still
in place where uh you know it's a
watchdog
uh sort of thing where they question the
water authorities as to what they're
doing and it was quite lively in those
days but i hear very little about it and
i wonder if we could find out whether
that uh independent representation still
continues to challenge what um what
south west water are doing
thank you is there an officer at the
back that could clear that point out
here and now
water voice
water watch is it
any comment any
so there is an organization such as that
right okay well we'll move on to
counselor david cox to speak please
yes i i brought up this issue and i was
told i was um i think i was told
i was grandstanding about this issue and
what is incredible is the difficulty in
getting anybody to hold southwest water
to account i don't know what water watch
is doing but we've seems to be pretty
much a toothless tiger when it comes to
dealing with southwest water because the
bonuses for um executives of southwest
water have been eye eye watering they're
you know millions of pounds they've been
given in in
bonuses and yet they are polluting our
our our river and mr vice chairman you
are the end of the line you get all the
all the discharges of sewage
if the other other pumping stations are
over over um uh
uh are over overcapacitated um but of
course at least it goes in the river so
we all get it frankly uh and we do
really need to hold uh southwest water
to account and i'm very pleased that you
questioned them very very hard we gave
them very hard questions when they came
but getting them to come to team bridge
to overview and scrutiny was a difficult
difficult
task and um
you know
french street in tinmath was left like a
abandoned building site with tomatoes
growing which tells you what was coming
out of the ground um
and that was left for a year and then
and then the tv arrived and the
newspaper arrived and suddenly it became
a priority for southwest water so i
think we do need to keep uh i know i'm
concentrating on southwest water there's
more to this motion than that so i'm
very very much welcome this motion i
hope we put um
put southwest water on the rack they are
giving
millions of pounds in bonuses and they
are polluting our rivers and the sea
all the time
thank you well i've got three more
speakers so far four now if you
encounter liam uh liam uh next so it'll
be nina jeffrey's first phil boulevant
second
sally morgan third and liam malone
fourth all right so
we need nina jeffrey's next
thank you
i just wanted to express my support for
this motion i come from a fishing family
in brixham
who've been largely affected over the
years of water quality
and i think it's really important to
broaden the view
within this and note the wider expertise
through giving value to the
environmental groups
um and fishing industries that would be
affected
um
i would love to see the aspirations
outlined in one of the points around
licenses to not have any licenses or
discharging
of any service at all but um
as we go i think this is a really good
promotion and i fully support it thank
you
next
thank you
thank you for the opportunity i'm
speaking
both as a counselor but also as vice
chair of the devon
pension fund which represents the
pension funds of uh
people in the public sector
in devon that controls about five and a
half billion pounds worth of investment
one of the approaches that the pension
funds have found successful in terms of
tackling climate change through
investments has been to recognize that
the investments that the pension funds
make
into these organizations are the source
of funds they use for investment and
also they are the recipients of the
majority of the bonuses or
dividends that they pay out
i think we whilst i totally endorse and
support the idea behind the motion i
think we're missing a trick here in that
we should be writing to the pension
funds because they are actually at the
call face of being able to influence
and direct companies to take the actions
that you're actually asking for here so
that encourage us to think beyond just
writing
this motion but ask you to also write to
pension funds asking them what they're
doing to control the investments that
they're making i think you'd get
a much bigger
return for that sort of approach
than just writing to the government
asking them to take the actions they're
in here thank you
[Music]
so sally morgan now
whoever wishes for a time machine to
take us back 32 years to 1989
and present this report i think we'd
probably be told we'd be scaremongering
um
i think i'd like to support this
wholeheartedly particularly section 8
where we call on the government
whoever's on stage at the time
um
particularly the section about the the
balance between consumer prices and
shareholders and long-term investment
because you know who who could have seen
um
you know this this happening maybe a few
of us maybe all of us
um i would like to have gone back you
know 32 years with this report and see
what the response that we'd get because
for some of us it's no surprise when
something that we already owned
as a society
is taken apart like this and used to
benefit a few very rich cats
sorry party political broadcast over
council liam malone
behind you
thank you um i find myself in the uh
ludicrous situation of agreeing entirely
with uh councillor david cox um
but as i support this uh this motion it
seems to me
uh that it will come to naught if
southwest water cannot be brought to
heal um when they made the presentation
to ons uh they fed us a load of the
stuff that they send out on the ebbtide
um it was it was just ridiculous um and
we got very very little out of them um
what they did let slip was first of all
they had absolutely no plans to
significantly improve their
infrastructure
regardless of how many houses are built
and and secondly they made mistakes such
as uh the holding tanks at pens mount
were allowed to flood into a very
sensitive part of
the river
because they'd forgotten to take over
the jurisdiction i mean these things are
just
appalling
so what i would like to see in this is
is
you know it's all very well saying we're
going to we're going to converse with
them we're going to email them i'd like
to see something saying we're going to
be on their backs we're going to be on
their backs constantly because the way
they are behaving is absolutely
appalling
right it's councillor martin wrigley
next and then councillor gary taylor
thank you very much um i too wish to
wholeheartedly support this nurse
emotion
in duelish we have been fighting these
battles for a long while i jokingly used
to refer to myself as the councillor for
sewerage when we were fighting southwest
water who were allowing
overflows from new estates to exceed the
capabilities of a six-inch pipe
where residents were having their homes
regularly flooded
very unpleasantly for a number of years
we did win that battle we persuaded
southwest water to upgrade that one
particular piece of infrastructure to
put in new holding tanks to reduce the
spills
we can
work with them and beat this problem but
it takes constant vigilance
having said that those spills didn't
just go into the teen we've talked a lot
about the teen let us not forget this
also impacts the x
so the accessory is an internationally
protected area and that is being spilled
into
from all of the areas up and down that
river too so we have plenty of
weapons in our arsenal to use and we
must use these and keep southwest water
i'm going to say keep them honest but
i'm not sure we ever get there but keep
them to account
thank you
councillor gary taylor now
thank you uh thank you chair uh yes i'd
very much like to
support
this motion also
this notice of motion
i'm a keen kayaker
i'm a sailor
i'm a swimmer too especially if i don't
sail very well
and
it is it is
really high time that uh the government
got tough with southwest water i note
that off what
very recently has said that southwest
water is on the list of companies that
they'll be looking at including southern
water
and hope that they really do
use the teeth that they should be
bearing
at these companies certainly with regard
to the the amount of money that is being
paid to directors i would echo
members views on that too i think it's
criminal
that we have such poor service and yet
they're being so highly rewarded it
really is bad um
martin rigley as casa martin rugby has
already told us about
the concerns
that have been raised in dawlish
throughout recent years and we've done
very well there to get the improvements
locally and i would thank southwest
water for those we've got a separation
now a separation tank in dawlish which
takes surface water to uh into the brook
rather than into the main sewer
which is helping in a small way achieve
some of the targets that should be that
should be
being looked at across our patch um and
i would also
echo the uh
with the the uh members concerns with
regard to the dumping of sewage off off
of either uh timmoth or off uh off of
dawlish and uh um i can remember the
banner uh being held up by one of the
doorish town councillors uh just three
years ago saying we begrudge the sludge
well i think i speak for everyone here
in saying we do begrudge the sludge and
we begrudge the money that's going to
south west water for giving this
district such a poor service thank you
councillor jackie hope
thank you
um if there's no one else um it doesn't
matter if there is but i'll do a quick
um going over some of the points and
summing up um
yeah the first action of the notice of
motion is to produce an action plan um
so you know i think graham smith's here
i'm here i've heard what's been said
in particular about how we communicate
and with southwest water and the
environment agency
i would say that we we have regular
communication with environment agency on
a number of project schemes etc
i'm not so sure it's quite so regular
with southwest water i know the teen s3
partnership has
someone from the ea on it i don't think
from southwest water so these these are
things that we can look at and put in
the action plan
um
and also you know you could have
southwest water back to scrutiny
you could have your mps back to talk
over the issue um and and specifically
maybe in regards to the wastewater
management plan which is currently out
for consultation so there's something
that you could look at and you know get
your teeth into in terms of what that's
um proposing
um
if if pension funds are relevant then
then obviously that can go into the
action plan as well but thanks for your
support and uh that's appreciated thank
you
well thank you very much members there's
a great deal of uh
support for everything from all sides of
the political domain here and it's
marvelous to see i would just like to
touch on this because
i've been one of the main uh shall we
say advocacies for southwest water to
get their act together we and thank you
for um
hugh cox
and david for getting hauling them
before ons which you know triggered all
this
and then a load of questions and it's
come to this and it's a terribly
interesting subject
in depth i mean they're telling us that
buckland is fit for purpose till 2035.
yet they've something like if you take
the minor tanks in
in the teen street catchment area there
was something like nearly 200 spills
that's if you include the one at stoke
netherton and and cumin teen head the
major tanks uh i think it was about 70
spills we had 52 spills at sheldon alone
and it was very interesting i made some
uh inquiries uh
they're pumping out of the holding tank
two thousand um cubic liters at tinmath
uh they're pumping at seven times the
speed that they are out of the half the
size tank we've got a a thousand cubic
feet of storage at sheldon we had
something like 52 pip spills from shawn
and i said well what happens because
it's all being fed into the one common
pipe which is about a meter i said what
actually happens is the shoulder and
pipe being overwhelmed by the speed of
the tinmuth pipe is that why we're
getting the spills at sheldon uh no it
says if you took the shortened pipe out
the the
the effluent would arrive from timothy
uh
at buckland he said if you just key that
into it
the an extra seventh arrives
in other words it all the sewage arrives
even faster at buckland
so
it's hard to see what on earth is going
on
really uh if we're getting so many
spills
and
buckland is supposed to be fit for his
purpose but it clearly isn't so
welcome what's been done here absolutely
superb and thank you for this huge
measure of support
for what the executive are doing here so
let's go to the vote
oh sorry
john
councillor john pesary
sorry to interrupt you at this delicate
stage but uh uh um i mean i i think back
to some of the planning developments
that have come before us at team bridge
and we've we've looked at them and
smith water a consultant we seem to
accept what they say now i'm thinking in
particular now i can think of a number
but in particular the most recent one is
the exeter road development in in
timbuth 220 dwellings and the surface
water there was just going to run down
the hill there's no provision to to put
it into suds or or divert it anywhere
else they're going to use natural
drainage for it to run down the hill so
it's 220 dwellings 220 roofs and garages
and driveways the surface water is just
going to run down the hill so so i i
wonder if we need to be more vigilant as
a planning committee and possibly if we
have concerns have southwest water in
attendance to get their reassurance that
what they're proposing is going to work
thank you chairman
thank you while we come to councilman
nina jeffrey uh uh
not neither jeffrey allison eden uh i
would just say that the ea i are the
monitoring body so although southwest
water at planning
we're told
uh
are a console t
it means absolutely nothing i think
with clout because the ea seemed to be
the monitoring body that if you like uh
well i won't say condoning it but it's
virtually condoning it isn't it
so you know that's the that's the
problem that we've got so over to
councillor allison eden
thank you very much um i just wanted to
observe that the um at government level
the conservatives have been in control
for 12 very long years
and in this situation they are literally
leaving us all in the pool
so when our local conservatives who in
this room are going oh isn't it dreadful
when are they either going to join the
liberal democrats or openly criticize
their own leaders thank you
well i i wouldn't like to answer that
one would i
i'm deliberately not going to answer of
course
councilman mcgregor
thank you i just i just want to
actually say a positive thing about the
environment agency um in in respect of
the efforts that they put in
the environment agency has been stripped
out
financially by the government so the
budgets that they've received have been
reducing steadily over the last
well since 2015 quite significantly so
they're they've lost staff
their the the amount of effort and um
and time they put into pursuing southern
water effectively made them take their
eye off the ball on united utilities in
the north the southwest water in the
south the two other worst uh offenders
and that unfortunately um
shows a priority because southern water
are the uh big south east
uh provider um and of course they're you
know a lot more um
there's a lot more money in that area
than there is in this area so
um and a lot more customers so they they
prioritized now that they've dealt with
southern water and they find them a huge
amount of money 90 million pounds
all we can hope is that southwest water
either
um
get their act together
wipe up the mess
and
um or get fined a huge amount of money
exactly like southern water
because these the southern water were
prevented from adding that to people's
bills it has to come from their bottom
line
and that is the uh that is the best way
to do it is attack these companies on
their bottom line and make sure that
they stop dumping effluent into our
waterways
two more uh speakers councillor russell
and councillor jules
uh thank you uh chairman we do have blue
flag beaches
in uh
timothy
warren
that will have an unfortunate impact on
our on our
on the criteria for blue flag beaches
and i think that's something that we
ought to raise with the environment
agency who are responsible for
designating the blue flag beaches
is it possible that we could have some
communication with the environment
agency to get their views about this
because there's some very strong
views been mentioned today and of course
it's going out to the public it's it's
it's on the airwaves and it's sending
out rather an unfortunate message
about our bathing waters when we are
designated as bathing water quality is
good um so we're sending out a mixed
message to the public here and really we
need to involve the environment agency
who are responsible for those
designations uh into our concerns thank
you
it goes to councillor david cox the mike
next all i would pick up on that point
is that
uh
messages go out not to bathe in the
water after sudden floods in the summer
time and hence we're we're getting
beaches
thank goodness past with flying colors
because um
at that point when we've got fine
weather we're not getting any spillages
so
you know it's great
that we're at least alerting the public
to to the times when the spills occur
and hopefully that's occurring
when you get heavy rainfall and things
can't cope
it's mixed in a majority of these
discharges are in the winter but we
still got to clear clear this
this mess up that's what i'm saying or
this issue up and and get southwest
water to get their house in order right
council cox
even in the winter people are swimming
in timber five would tell people it's
got a subtropical climate um but people
are swimming all year round wild swim
swimming is now the um
a popular pastime for people but i was
very interested what uh councillor
pedrick had to say because of course
southwest waters say oh yes modern
buildings do not do not have combined
sewers therefore we can't charge
developers for um
for other things we can't deal with the
the combined cells which combine runoff
and sewage
but if they build as councillor patrick
said their water runs off and where does
it go some of it must go into combined
sewers and we should shouldn't let them
off the hook by saying
oh yes new new developments are purely
purely sewage system they have a runoff
effect
um global warming does have a an issue
regarding we're getting more rainfall in
one go which is over overloading the the
combined cells which predate probably
southwest water
there's a lady in timber who's whose
drains have been done by southwest water
because of the 1836 tim of improvement
act the local water authority which used
to be the council has to deal with her
trains but
clearly the building is contributing uh
to uh the issues of flooding and sewage
um
being put into the rivers overflows
because of the runoff and perhaps we
need to look into this a bit more and
start saying to developers because
believe me they'll force southwest water
to do something developers need to pay
for something to be done about the
overflows
disagree with you at all
thank you for making those points
as councillor taylor and then there's
councillor phipps and alice
i'd like to wrap this up after that if i
may because we all seem to be in much
agreement
just to briefly respond to councillor
cox there is a planning guidance and
there's a sequential view taken on
on surface water
and initially it's filtration so into a
soak away then it would be suds
sustainable urban drainage systems
and then finally into open water course
thank you
phipps was next
thank you
and for that enlightenment and on the
original plans for the development in
extra road
the runoff order was to go into storage
tanks
and then be transported away by tanker
lorry
so i don't know if that's still on the
plans but according to councillor taylor
that has been altered has that been
altered or is it is is that or was i
correct
you know
well it's a i'm not aware of the water
being transported off it doesn't sound
very sustainable so i wouldn't i
wouldn't uh agree to that being a
sustainable
urban drainage system
that was in the original plan so
thank you
thank you for that
yes i mean i was curious about this
because i assumed that there would be
suds but apparently because of the very
slope sleeping ground that's not not one
of the options and they were going to
use natural drainage well the natural
drainage was the field when it rained
the water permeated into the field some
of it would run down the hill but now
with all these buildings on it the wall
all the water is going to run down the
hill there's nowhere for it to permit
it's going to go into
the brook at the at the bottom of timbus
yeah
thank you
thank you very much chair um so i just
wanted to point out that uh section
eight f
um lists a whole raft of measures that
this council would take
to encourage government
to uh to to help these matters
and particularly paragraph three of f
which it says cease making cuts to the
environment agency funding
and i think that's absolutely vital
because without their help
we
we're just shouting in the wind one
final thing
we keep talking about the river teen
which is obviously
in the middle of our district and we've
talked about the river x
but of course much of my ward
and parts of ambrook also flow into the
river dart and we have a duty to protect
that as well
thank you
councillor hook do you want to sum up
again with all the views that have been
coming forward very briefly you're happy
right let's go to the vote on this as a
great deal if you now take those in
favor
unanimous thank you very much
yes um
councillor mcgregor
thank you um it was to cover my second
personal explanation um
earlier in the the discussion i uh made
a a statement um in which i suggested
that uh counselor balloon was against
sill
and he asked me to withdraw the remark
saying it was defamatory um apart from
the fact that that would not necessarily
be even close to defamatory um i refer
councillor bulovan back to his comments
at the 20th of september meeting in
which he suggested that sill
was damaging to the housing market
um in an astonishing display of not
understanding how the housing market
works either
so
and then we had an exchange within the
press
um in which um
council obviously accused me of being um
to the left of karl marx but he couldn't
even spell his name correctly
um so from that perspective my position
on this is i won't withdraw my remark
and i'm not going to apologize
for comments that council boulevard made
himself at the 20th of the september
meeting thank you
just one second where i have a word with
solicitor please
[Music]
something that the solicitor has drawn
my attention to
which is
8 413 personal explanation
a member may make a personal explanation
at any time a personal
explanation may only relate to some
material part of an earlier speech by
the member which may appear to have been
misunderstood in the present debate
the ruling of the chair on this
admissibility of a personal explanation
will be final
on the strength of that
i would like to make a personal
statement about an ambiguity raised by
councillor mcgregor towards me earlier
on in the
meeting
councillor eden raised a subject uh
which has been discussed many many times
before
i did not barrack her i looked at the
chair and suggested we move on
councillor mcgregor
then
physically moved his chair aggressively
towards me
turned around
shouted in my face very closely that i
was shouting
that if i was shouting the whole room
would hear
i would therefore request councillor
mcgregor apologizes for his physical and
verbal abuse
thank you
members please
as i mentioned before
and i had a nice debate with
councillor doors didn't we let's be
respectful to one another
and agree to differ all right
there are going to be times when we
differ i'd like to move on please
otherwise we're going to be here
richard
well
if you can make it quickly rules be
broken but it is something we discussed
uh
just uh in the break and it's it's about
the uh conflicts of interest and
declaring interest because i declared an
interest at the start of the meeting
of founding a charitable bull
community benefit society which
is relating to the alexandria theatre
that
theater is going to be included in the
next motion uh so uh i had uh suggested
to the monitoring officer that i uh when
he suggested to me during the break that
i'd be uh
breaking a a criminal offense actually
uh if if i remained in the room uh if i
could speak to the motion and not vote
but uh that what that dispensation
wasn't offered uh i asked if i could
stay in the room uh as a member of the
public i was that was suggested that my
presence was clearly too strong uh to to
stay in the room so i i'm gonna step out
of the next motion uh i'll take my time
to actually write a speech i've been
invited by the theater's trust to a
conference on the future of british
theater so uh given this council's
ignored me for two years and now
silencing me
i'll i'll go and give my voice to the uk
theatre industry instead thank you
thank you
right we move on please uh to uh
the notices of motion now that will be
presented uh
in item 13 the lead present
uh it if i may item 13. chairman can i
just clarify that the member was given
advice that he has the option to choose
how he takes that advice it wasn't an
instruction
and it was clearly that the
revised code of practice that came
it was the revised code of practice it
was adopted by this council sets out
that if you are a director of a company
even if you're a non-profit resi sorry
non-remunerated in terms of that there
is a potentially a conflict of interest
we had to advise the council of that it
was up to the councillor to take that
advice and do with it as he pleases
now you know
i i i think that it was slightly unjust
the way that was framed but thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
is a charity trustee different from a
director of a company or society sorry
paul's looking this up for you david
i'm just simply chair sorry i'm just
going to get
the permanent
well it's clear that we're probably not
going to finish
the meeting before yeah i'll come back
to paul
we're not going to finish the meeting
before uh
quarter one or so we will break for
lunch then because i don't think the
meeting will be finished by then the way
it's going uh just take that point uh
because there's questions after this
this will be a lengthy one in itself by
the look of it but anyway paul's gonna
paul woodhead i'll say this is gonna
reply to you david
thank you chair members
um a little bit disappointed that we
were having to
um
clarify what what went off during the
debate sorry during the adjournment
council
dawes
is a
director
of an organization which is a regulated
organization
he's declared that quite properly
the council's code of conduct that
appendix uh the appendix to the
council's code of condom
states that a disclosable pecuniary
interest
under
underemployment
means any employment office trade
profession or vocation carried on for
profit or gain and any unpaid
directorship
i brought that to the council's
attention because
given that that
creates a disclosable pecuniary interest
should the council have remained in the
chamber
taken part in the discussion
he would have committed a criminal
offence if it was a disclosable public
interest i merely brought that to the
attention of the councillor concerned
and advised him
as i've just set out to you
and
gave to him a choice and the choice was
a matter for him to make
thank you
councillor wrigley
uh thank you very much
this situation comes up quite frequently
uh councillor hook and myself are
directors of the newton abbott cic
and we disclose that when we're talking
about the issues and i believe that is
quite correct
i personally would support councillor
doors to be in the room and part of the
conversation he has disclosed his
interest i was at a meeting yesterday
when they were talking all about this
new vehicle and what it was attempting
to do and i don't believe at this point
there would be any significant conflict
that should prevent him from staying and
taking part in this debate
councilman malone
these are these items
i know these items on the agenda but i'm
doing my best to try and bring this
council together rather than have
division
all right so
that's the way i it's my style of
chairmanship that's all
this this what's happening here is just
it's just it's just ridiculous i mean
this act of silencing in effect in
effect tells you know councillors that
you know
they can't if they support
or or form community trusts of any kind
they can be excluded they can be
silenced and the people that they
represent can be completely
disenfranchised this is just a
completely ad hoc
and persecutory interpretation of the
constitution and more to the point it's
against the law
you're in violation of laws of free
association of free speech and of civic
representation uh the monitoring officer
is breaking the law
chairman chairman can i be clear that
this is the lga's model code that we've
adopted
this is the it isn't against the left
hand laws
let's be clear if we're taking advice
from experts we've taken advice from the
lga and the model code we've taken
advice from the head of legal services
i'll leave that with you councillors we
were giving advice to a council the
council can choose to take that advice
did not it was not an instruction it was
not an absolute it was there giving him
advice to help him in that decision
because if the challenge is made then we
he was aware and alive to the
consequences of a challenge or a legal
case
i'll leave it as that but this is the
lga's model code if you want to go and
look at the lga models code please do it
may help you in your information and
your understanding
if you can keep your points short i will
allow members to speak because i don't
want if you like
to have all this diversity so keep your
points short please counselor david cox
i appreciate what is being said by the
monitoring officer and the managing
director their hands are tidy it was
that but
we have put
counselor doors has been excluded
because he chose a form of
charitable
audit organizat so i would have gone
with the charity
to see a cicio or cic a company but
if he'd been on for cic he'd have been a
director it is a certain amount of
semantics because if he's chosen to go
for a charity
uh like tim of pavilions uh he would be
a and he would be a trustee and he'd be
allowed to stay as long as he declared
his interest so perhaps it's something
to go back to um the procedures
committee because there's a downside
difference between a profitable company
director being renumerated and a
benefit society director uh you know
quite a few of us i think here are
trustees so we could
it would be it was it seems to go
against the spirit i understand the
letter of the law and the monitoring
officer and the managing director's uh
hands are tied they needed to tell
council the door but we ought to send it
back to
procedures because this is not what
that's not what was intended i don't
think by the lga thing it's it's the
wording we need to uh
i don't know that perhaps perhaps
i'm gonna i don't know if it's society
needs to rename his director's trustee
in the interest of moving it on i am not
gonna allow everybody to speak all in
sundry on this he did go on his own
volition
he was threatened i don't think so liam
well
he he was told he was told the position
in order for legal action to happen
somebody's got to take that legal action
against him now who's going to take that
legal action against him for breaking a
code of conduct
as it as it's written
that's that's the point that i make he's
going now let's let's
in fairness not argue this till
you feel like forever and ever i think
the time has come to move on to the
serious business of this council which
is the next motion
all right so let's move it on sorry
yes
before this motion comes up uh we were
promised that officers would be
providing reports on this matter not a
motion from
the leader of the council uh that was
stated at the last full council meeting
by the leader he said that officers
would go forward a report can i clarify
can i clarify for you yeah no no the
leader did ask for a report
we advise the leader that we couldn't
update him with anything that was prior
to the business case that was agreed in
february and the uh monitoring report
that was provided by
sorry the section 151 officer gave an
update of whether the budget was within
there we advised that
where we are in the project
we couldn't provide anything that
updated members at this point and we
would do that as in when more
information came forward we've been
working
weekly daily on this project so we did
commit to that as in when anything would
change what i didn't commit to was we
would endeavor to get a report to this
committee it wasn't an absolute
counsellor
thank you phil um just just on that that
matter it does surprise me that we
weren't updated prior to the meeting
that that wasn't going to happen then
thank you
councillor patch
thank you chad we'll try and be brief on
this um just with regard to the
conversation we had about
advice being offered
i thank councillor wrigley for pointing
out the situation of of himself and
council hook but just for clarity really
and i'm sure i'm not the only member who
would like this clarity i'm unsure that
the
situation if council is wrigley in hook
situation is different from councillor
doors and if it if it isn't different
um
should they be offered the same advice
the same legal advice about their
participation the advice is there in the
code isn't it the the
one member has been actively approached
and um advised about the possibility of
criminal action and two members in what
seems to me to be a similar situation
haven't been
paul woodhead our sister is best place
to respond
thank you chair members um i'll set out
an advice note for members if
that would be helpful
by whether the members newsletter or
somewhere else about the issues around
trusteeship and such like
to enable this to move on i i
[Applause]
shall i say somewhat
surprised at the response to
an attempt to assist a councillor
in um
uh enjoying the german
to um bring to his attention
potential consequences to
um
actions he may take
maybe going forward i simply don't do
that and
go from there thank you chair
right well it's quarter to one i said we
pretty well it's
two minutes away we're going to be here
after lunch
so
would you mind if i introduce the motion
so that people can decide whether they
want to stay or go over lunch
yeah i think anything
would be helpful
chairman thank you very much um may i
ask council
now ask council if would be willing to
uh vote in favor of debating discussing
the motion today it's not possible for
it to stand a german somewhere else as
it pertains i understand to a matter of
decided by council at an earlier meeting
may i ask for a vote in favor of the
discussion debate today
certainly are you proposing two-thirds
wish to debate it we have a second for
that a show of hands then please for two
thirds
um to debate it
we've got to get the numbers right here
please keep your hands nice and vertical
so
sarah can count
yeah and myself
i think we ought to have it debated
chairman thank you for that and thank
you to colleagues for enabling the
discussion i will i've got a a statement
prepared if i can read it chairman then
if colleagues wish to break for lunch
absolutely that's a good time to reflect
that'd be brilliant thank you so so so
chair the motion is put before council
to confirm the broadest support for the
future high street fund while navigating
a positive way forward for the one issue
about which there is clear difference
i believe there is unity across the
chamber and beyond in welcoming the 9.2
million secured through the future high
street fund to announce newton ham
newton abbott
there is broad support for a new
multi-screen cinema and in saying this i
make no comment about the current
planning application so as not to
predetermine the matter and during
debate i asked councillors to also avoid
the risk of predetermination too
we have committed to continuing newton
abbott's proud 800-year history as a
market town and our ambition is for it
to be devon's premier market tone there
is though clear division with regard to
the alexandra building
that division in my personal view risks
are snatching economic defeat from the
jewels of victory for newton abbott and
the wider district if together we cannot
find a new way forward that delivers the
things we have broad agreement on and
looks afresh at the alex
subject to a further report setting out
options for the alex i believe that it
would be possible to focus on the market
hall as a market and the planned eatery
this would enable the wall between the
alex and the market all to remain
the alex could be considered outside the
scope of the future high street fund
however the impacts of such a decision
on the council's case to the future high
street fund will need to be assessed and
be subject to the government's green
light for such a change i understand
officers will need to bring a new report
to council's consideration setting out
options for the alex for example and not
restricted to
would the council wish to sell the
freehold of the alex or a long lease
how do we ensure any new operator
actually does provide a comprehensive
year-round arts and cultural programme
understanding what if any impact there
is on cancer budgets of isolating the
alex from the future high street fund
if councillors agree to this new
approach there is significant work to be
done and a closing window of time to
december when the council must submit
its next stage of the
future high street funds of the
government
speaking personally and without
committing the council or its offices
i believe it might well be possible that
an arts and cultural community groups
and organizations could be invited to
submit initial proposals within the
first few months of the new year with a
full business plan in say june or july
this would give those with an interest
real time to work together prepare their
plans with decisions taken forward by a
new council i restate this is simply my
view
for now
colleagues i suggest there are three
options before the council and they are
these
carry on as already endorsed by the
council
two stop completely and do nothing
three
endorse the intent of this motion
i invite the council to support the
third endorse the intent of this motion
because in doing so it supports a new
multi-screen cinema for newtonaba
remodeling the market hall to encompass
the planned eatery
looking afresh at the options for the
alex probably outside the scope of the
future high street fund thank you
chairman
thank you very much so uh how long would
you like now to break for
we haven't got any lunch here as such so
why is it going to have to be 30.
right it's 15 minutes so it's uh ten to
one now we'll see you back at temp um
what is it five past one is that
[Music]
thank you everybody for coming back and
hopefully
we won't be breaking any records for the
longest council meeting here today
so uh like to try and press on if we can
keep things
fairly succinct if we can
so thank you
to alan connect for
uh outlining the the uh the motion in
item 13
and so i'm going to open it up for
debate as bina has there been a second
or a proposal we haven't
you seconded it you proposed it
right okay so i'm opening it up for
debate try and keep your comments to the
minimum if you can
constantly
yeah thank you chair um
i for one would like to also support
part of this motion
and all of it if we get some sort of uh
agreement
the first three items
on the proposal
are uh
quite logical and
i can see the step way forward so i've
no no problems at all with the first
three items of this proposal or this
motion
we then come on to four five and six
which uh
which is where i think we need some sort
of clarity
number four it says review proposals for
existing market hall in order to propose
the market offers
to draw in new traders and more
customers and we've heard the leader
already say today that uh the war
between the market hall
and the alexander theater stroke
cinema
will remain
uh and that's what they'll be looking at
and i too agree with this
if we cast our minds back two or three
meetings ago of this full council
three or four of us tried to try to
say then
that we could have a win-win situation
if
we
only looked at the two building one
building as two separate items
the market hall could
could be enhanced could have exactly
what the accounts what this council
s his ambitions are for that market hall
with a new mesonated floor
put in
and at that time
those
ideas were poo pooed
hopefully we can now
start talking sensibly with this council
and those proposals can be rooked out in
realistically
and can
increase the
um
the footfall and that into the market
hall with a new mesonated floor with the
cafe or bar or whatever you want on that
floor and the trade-in and traders on
the ground floor
it says to commission a season of street
performance
uh to draw more people into the town
great don't disagree
i hope that this council will talk to
the
um
town centre manager sally henley in
order that we're not duplicating um
things that's going on in the town that
she manages to put on or in fact works
with her to enhance what's being put on
in the town center
if that if we get that sort of agreement
then again i can support this motion
and finally we come to the perhaps the
number of the matter
and that is to
that is to consider a fresh option for
the alexander theater stroke cinema
building
again i welcome this
i see this councilors as
this council
just providing a crack in that door that
was shut
to us
several weeks ago
and that crack we can now push against
and i hope
that um through this debate we will get
the sense that this council is willing
to talk to the organizators
organizations which
want to improve the alexander theater
alongside a new cinema which we won't go
into because as the leader has
alluded to um it is due to a planning
application
but i went to a meeting last night of
the
heart of tingbridge cultural
group which
um
councilor dawes actually
uh alluded to earlier on to say that he
had become
a director of the cbs which was set up
and at that meeting
again
plans were put forward
that we tried to bring to this council
several weeks ago
which were done by architect um
jeremy newcomb
uh
he he brought four plans those plans
have now been progressed even more
um there is uh now um
costings etc for those plans
and i hope that this council is
genuinely enough to actually now talk to
this group and to actually try and move
this
this
project forward
i believe that we are in a situation we
were in a situation several weeks ago
until the door was shut
we're now back in that situation with
this door slightly ajar where we can
have a win-win situation for newton
abbott we can create
a cultural hub which would include a new
cinema
a new refurbished and upgraded
uh
theater
stroke
cultural hub
and an and a more realistic
uh market hall that will benefit not
just the traders
but residents and visitors alike
so with that
i will know that someone else speak
but i hope that this council can secure
then
convince me that their feelings and i'm
sure they are i just need convincing
that their feelings and the open door is
open for us now to negotiate and for us
to come to some sort of final thing that
we all get what we want thank you
now going to councillor alan connect the
leader to see whether he can accommodate
some of your demands and what we're
seeking here before we have anybody else
to speak thank you
i'm grateful to councillor hocking for
what he says and i think i can provide
some reassurances in some of the areas
certainly there's been commentary in the
past about uh splitting out the alex and
having a different set of proposals for
that as i recall and i may have
misunderstood and apologize if i have we
had all been talking about it as though
it were part of the overall future high
street fund the damascene sort of vision
as it were what's different about this
uh
motion and what i said in my injury
comments to it um where that
the alex would be taken out of the
future fund we would treat it
differently the future high street fund
will continue with the cinema proposal
with the market hall but the alex will
be treated differently and i think
that's that's the difference between
then and now
what i'm also clear about and i hope i
made clear my commentary is that
we would want or the council will want
to invite
the range of interest from
more than one group there may be other
groups
within the community that also have
ambitions or expert they may all come
together chairman i i don't set out that
it is just one group or a preferred
group but simply that the council having
identified a change of approach would
want to draw in a wide range of
expressions of interest and hence i
talked about people having ample time to
think about their ideas maybe come
together maybe to pursue their
individual proposals but the council at
a later date would invite those
expressions of interest and give ample
time
for full business cases to be worked up
and i tried to indicate what type of
timeline that might be
i think council hockey makes a very good
point around
the proposal for street performances
which is why the motion says
commission a season of street
performances rather than simply provide
and that was to leave it open so that we
would obviously want to work
complementary with the town council
i don't know what uh arrangements there
may be for the town council for 2023
but if members are minded to support
this what it indicates is an approach on
the council to support improved enhanced
street performances and quite rightly i
would expect as i no doubt counselor
hocking is as well that the district
council will work with the town council
and others and even an emergent culture
and community group in order to
provide those things german so i think i
hope i've answered
councillor hawking's
questions and given him the reassurances
as best i can provide here today and i
do invite all colleagues to support the
motion is set out
um there was a slight flag i just
stopped by saying i do endorse totally
everything that councilor hawking said
um there was a slight flag raised for me
in
the leader's present presentation
prior to our break and what he's just
said in that the this idea of separating
off the alex and not including it in the
future high streets fund um as i i would
think there's a very good case
bearing in mind the jeremy newcomb plans
which have been very comprehensively
worked up and i gather business plan
work has been done alongside of that
um
i really don't see the logical argument
for trying to exclude that from this
project going forward i mean i must be
honest putting us a slight cynical
head-on for a change um it seems to me
that the executive wants to say yes
we've changed our mind we've had a
damascene conversion
but by golly we're not going to be seen
to be admitting that we were wrong a few
months ago when we ruled out this
application it seems to me that with
this money available
very active consideration should be
given to including the jeremy you can
plan go
into the um into the various options
going forward and and that moves on to a
second point i'd like to make i'm quite
bemused that um was it three four months
ago how i think it might be approaching
six months ago um we were told there's
no time there's no time to revisit plans
we have to do it now that's why we can't
look at the german new can plan
and now we're being told oh hang on
we'll take the foot off the pedal we we
can we can wait a few months maybe next
year but when it when in fact we've got
a ready-made proposal
that would allow a much tighter time
scale that would not jeopardize the loss
of these millions of pounds that are on
offer to come into um the area so i i
would just flag those issues really i
think very active considerations should
be given to the inclusion of the german
you can plan as a viable alternative
and that perhaps in light of that we
should be a bit more optimistic on time
scales
names of counselors down councillor
bullaven
councillor cox and councillor linda
pedreck and i expect there'll be others
all right so let's do it in that order
i've said councillor phil bulovan please
thank you
i think everybody in this room would
like to find a resolution for the use of
the alex and hopefully that can
incorporate the
high street
theater as well
my question really is one of uncertainty
from
my own point of view and i'd appreciate
some clarity please
the high street fund is a government
grant of 9.2 million and as all
government grants come with conditions
applied
and time scales attached
either an officer present who could
actually
explain what the implications or
ramifications are of any deviation or
change to that process would be
and i'd find that extremely extremely
helpful the second question is
i understand that the 9.2 million was
based on a preliminary series of designs
and
numbers of options and you know the
cinema the other works that were
associated with it
if we are proposing to do something for
the alex to create the alex theater
how would the additional if there are
additional costs incurred with that can
teambridge
contribute towards those additional
costs or did it have the facilities
to enable it to do so thank you
i'm going now to
um
neil blaney to see if he can answer some
of those questions that councillor
bullavent has posed
uh thank you chair um yeah accountable
events correct the
uh the award the the grant funding um is
over a three year period um so all
monies need to be spent by march 2024.
when we submitted our bid we set out um
what expenditure should there be per
year so we set out
the way the process works is we set out
how much we're going to have each year
the government will then fund on a
yearly basis
and in december the year before the next
award or the drawdown we set out where
we are in terms of progress
how much we spent and then what's going
to happen in the next year has to be in
any variation do we bring things forward
we push it back is it on track
so
um at the moment we are working towards
the scheme as uh approved by members
with the drawdowns coming through in
this next year
we need to report back to government in
december to say how we've got on and
then where we're going to be into next
year so it was one of the risks we were
going to flag uh to members that um i
think councillor patches mentioned when
this was discussed in february last year
we said time was against us it still is
so there is a risk with with um any
delays we would need to
look at alternatives that need to be
costed and reviewed in the same way that
the original submission was done we
haven't been presented with any
information
on the business case for alternative
plans it was discussed uh in detail and
so members have obviously considered
voted on and we've moved forward on the
basis of what was before us
so
i can't say now where that will leave us
clearly any pause
on a time scale that's um expending the
money by march 2024
puts that money at risk so it's a
decision that we've been making with a
great deal of uncertainty um and uh we
would need to look to commission again
the same consultant to help support the
original bid
and if we were going to look and council
con mentioned before we report back in
december with certainty what that change
request would be so i think it's been
debated previously about can we change
our submission um and we've always said
we can but we need to have the evidence
and the business case to demonstrate
that what we've got is deliverable
when government review how much we've
spent and what we're proposing to spend
it's in the member and the membrane of
understanding that we sign with
government
that when they look at the review they
can make a decision as to whether they
support it whether they've got concern
or whether they may decide
they may wish to withhold the funding
because they're not convinced that it'll
be spent within the set time period so
that'll be the next step if members were
to agree today to progress
i think we'd need clarity on
specifically what options that we'd be
considering
because clearly we've looked at some in
the development of the bid in the first
place it's part of the
evaluation process which started back in
2018 for future high street funds which
is an expression of interest then a an
outline business case we secured funding
to develop a detailed business case
and we use the
treasury green book evaluation process
which we can send the link out for
everyone to see it
there's multiple
assessments that go alongside that so
it's quite a detailed
bit of work and it's called the five
case business model um it's not just a
straightforward we submit our bid and
they give us the money
we also need to look at a strategic case
so why is this funding needed what it's
um what it's aimed at objectives and
economic case is it value for money
i have a range of options being
considered and that's a really important
part of all of this is that
consideration of options is fundamental
to the green book approach so we need to
make sure we've tested everything
and we've got the best
balance of cost benefits and risk
there's the commercial case is it viable
um and can we secure a deal for the
money there's a financial case is it
affordable
because this isn't just government money
it's also the
district council's money so we've got to
make sure costs are realistic and
affordable
and that the funding does cover
everything that we're looking at and
then the management case of is it
achievable
so we need to be able to answer all of
those questions so when we go forward
with any alternative proposal if we were
to take an alternative plan back to
government we need to be able to
demonstrate along those grounds that the
options that we are now considering um
meet those objectives um i think future
high street fund if we were to go back
with a proposal that did um you know
don't think they'd have an issue
necessarily with uh amendments to the
plan but it's having that alternative
case to having something robust and
reliable and given us certainty that if
we do go forward
it will be accepted so
i can't answer any more than that at the
moment we don't know until
we get to that point
we've got
another thing that members just need to
be aware of is
we've been progressing in line with the
council resolution in february last year
sorry this year
so there's a number of uh aspects that
are in motion um in terms of preparing
the sites we've got the application in
for the for the cinema but we've also
got to start preparing um for the next
step which should be demolition of
buildings um
ending of leases
looking at diversions of utilities um
and sort of what's going to go on and
the next step of pre-ordering um things
for the construction so there's costs
involved with that um there's been a
slight pause
but the next stage if we're looking at
some of these is
we've got an enabling cost of about 300
000 pounds
which would be needed to to enable the
cinema element to it and that doesn't
add any value to our real estate um it's
funded through the grant at the moment
um but obviously decisions we make today
we need to consider what the the
knock-on or the consequences might be
for some other elements of those
projects um and
if we pause those
again the timeline issue comes into play
in that
we've set out a timeline to meet the
delivery of this project by 2024. not
the whole project because this is about
the drawdown of the government money by
march 2024 there are still the district
council's contribution which can be
after
march 2024 so you can still um
bring some uh push some of that a little
bit further back but the bulk of it and
being able to use the government money
needs to be spent by march 2024
so that's quite thank you for neil
blamey for outlining that in
detail and next on the item to speak was
counselor david cox
followed by linda pedreck followed by
councillor andrew mcgregor
i'm in the unusual position of agreeing
totally with what mike had to say and um
i'm very pleased that there's going to
be a charitable benefit society i'm not
sure that was necessarily the right
status to have but it's useful that
could that could act as a as a an
organization that would run the
um the alexandra building as a as an
arts center so that that's quite a
positive step um and i think
i agree totally agree with mike we need
to win win we need to we need to you
know perhaps we need to eat humble pie
as a council but let's get it right for
the people and work together but it
doesn't it does take two to tango so
everybody's got to
start to agree to work together uh it is
a slight problem with
the future high streets fund whether
that can be used for the alexandria
because remember as a charitable
benefits as an exempt charity there will
be grants that the um
effectively the people running the
building i hope
can get so it may not be that that fund
can be used for a charitable um
institution it may they may need to go
to grants need to go for grants for
awards for
the arts council
but that's i think really positive i
think we need to pass this motion today
and find fiddle the detail in uh towards
the uh
with the various parties but i think we
should support this motion today
thank you david uh next is councillor
linda pesary
i agree with what mike has said as well
but there's just some some things that
i'd like to ask some questions
you know i remember when we were when
this all got brought to council and i
actually feel for the officers who have
done all the work on this project
and one of the questions is will they
now have to start from scratch and
rework this bid again
what impact will these changes have on
the funding bed
we were all told it was time limited so
i'm surprised that you know a few
months later we're coming back and
saying that we now got the time to
change it
because we were told that the plans
couldn't be changed
and i'm a bit concerned about what we
will be reporting back to the government
in december
um about how we how things have suddenly
changed and
i want to know why has the executive
change their minds i want to understand
why why this has been brought back and
changed so completely
are you in a position uh counselor
to answer sort of lyndon at this stage
rather than yeah i can pick up a number
of the questions chairman um
in terms of uh cancer bulletin um
could teambridge you know for example
contribute to additional costs um the
essence of the motion was to try and
gauge
um
the appetite for members for carrying on
as was set out previously
to stop and just say well we're not
going to continue anymore or whether
there is an appetite
for some change which recognized
the issues around the alex i think there
is broad
consensus around a cinema and around the
market hall and as i identified when i
spoke prior to the lunch break about the
eatery being included up there and that
creates an opportunity
um
when we met last time i don't think
anyone said there couldn't be changes
because we knew that other councils had
made changes and i think officers
rightly pointed out that it wasn't on a
whim it required
work and evidence and
to identify why that was about
what we've all spoken about at least as
i recall was about the alex being part
of an intrinsic part of the futuristic
fund the bid that the council had
originally made
the invitation i'm making to council now
is to say look if we
if we want to keep the wall up and we
want the alexandra to be uh a cultural
venue
it might be possible for us to take it
out so the future issue fund continues
um we work on the cinema and the market
but actually we look at the
alexandra in a different way and that
may make a difference
but it also provides scope because part
of the issue has been about
who who would have the alex i know there
are interested
organizations or an interested
organization but it it's not for council
today to presume it's any one provider
there may be other providers there may
be a group of providers who want to get
together with the organization that's
been put together just recently we want
to draw together the best and we want to
give them time to think about funding to
think about their business case and not
to be rushed
officers are working
against the clock and as uh neil blaney
said we have to submit our next stage
response to government in december
officers have assured me that while it
will be a push
we have the capacity to do this bit of
work which if the alex was taken out we
can do the other work around how that
works around the market what the impacts
might be and to put together the best
case to government
um
now counselor linda petrick asks we were
told the plans couldn't change and i i
mentioned that i believe when we spoke
previously it was recognized they could
change and i understand although i've
not seen it um
personally that yeovil so somerset
district council yeovil
had applied for a change which had been
granted um will officers now need to
work from scratch now i don't believe
they're going to need work from scratch
they haven't told me that you know
there's a body of work and as i
understand it if members are minded to
support the motion we will need to
commission some additional work but i
suspect a lot of that will be based on
research that's already
being done but some new work will need
to be in hand there will be some costs
in this but if the prize for everyone
is a cultural center based on the
alexandra building
then my view as leader of the council
was that most members maybe all members
would understand that and say
okay you know this is what we want to do
we're mindful about the opportunity here
edging patch cancer patch says
he detects a slight flag no not actually
no no flag on my part uh there is an
ambition uh to
reach out and
offer a change um there is an ambition
on my part
to ensure that those groups that may
have an interest in the alexandra
building have the best possible lead
time to consider their ideas work
together come together and if they want
to or if they're going to submit
separate bids
but they come together and have their
time to do that um so i do understand
council apache's concern uh but that's
not the motivation here there's no
there's no sense for me about being foot
off the pedal so much as trying to give
people the chance for newton abbott to
get the best from this chairman
councillor cox spoke and he invited
people to support the motion um and i
you know i support that view too
right we've got councillor andrew
mcgregor then councillor liam malone and
councillor patch wants to come back for
a second time briefly i hope
thank you chair um
as the debate's gone on one or two
points have become clear so my my uh
question and and kind of
direction has changed slightly uh
counselor uh counselor um connet has
mentioned the fact that the need we we
need to find out whether there are other
interested parties now bearing in mind
this has been an extremely public
debate over the alexandria theatre for
the last year and a half
um and that there's been exchanges
backwards and forwards uh with various
groups
in support it does surprise me that that
you know we're now talking about then
going out and finding more people so if
we are going to do that i suggest we put
an absolute time scale in of a maximum
of four weeks we advertise
that and we put out for four weeks it's
been in the public domain for 18 months
people have had lots and lots of
opportunities to to engage
and several people have been engaged and
of course i'm quite sure that we have
all seen the emails back a few uh last
year that um
show that uh at least one of those
groups was rebuffed in its attempts to
to to try and get
um changes done on the alexandria
theater but let's let's let's focus away
from that
sorry did you want to interject phil
yes
i appreciate what you say counselor i
think there is an issue with um the
council's duty to achieve best value and
ensuring that we can have an adequate
time for other groups who may wish to
come forward who didn't think this
opportunity was there so i would have to
support
the leaders view that it would be a time
to take
just determining that you want to give
it to one group wouldn't guarantee best
value for taxpayers
or the opportunity for others to to bid
into that sense so
it would be probably something that
myself and
the monetary officer and the section 151
officer would resist in terms of your
proposal for four weeks because that
wouldn't be an adequate time
in terms of us getting
the information and then being able to
evaluate that that's probably too short
i'm sorry
okay thank you phil
um so in in terms of you know going back
um last year that um at least one group
was rebuffed in its attempts to um thing
so talking about engagement does seem a
little bit um
of an interesting subject at this stage
but let's not forget the future high
street fund isn't just about the
alexandra theatre there are elements to
it as well so we need to be cognizant of
the idea that whilst the alexander
theatre is extremely important
it's not the whole story here but coming
back to the alexander theatre because it
is quite obviously the topic of
discussion particularly around one of
the clauses in the motion
is that the idea was that it was going
to be retained but that that isn't
actually accurate what they were talking
about was returning the market hall to
its entirety
with a performance stage in the middle
of the the market hall that wasn't
retaining the alexandra theatre at all
and that's a significant change and when
it comes to planning and this is where
the assumptions are being made
unless i'm mistaken here the assumption
is that planning is just going to be a
breeze through we're talking about a
grade two listed building
as it stands at the moment it's not a
grade two listed building for when it
was built in 1860 whatever or even 1927
when it was created
um as a market hall and cinema it was it
was listed
relatively recently within the last 60
years
and it's as it stands at the moment so
changes to that building now
are going to take a significant amount
of analysis and planning
so not changing it might actually be a
benefit because it means that we don't
actually have to then change anything we
don't have to make a planning
application for it so we save money
there i'm assuming the current residents
our current tenants would have to do a
restitution
to the the condition of the building as
it was when they took on the lease
so they would be expected to do that
whereas if if there is included in the
in the future high street fund what we
are talking about then is they get away
with that and we have then have to fork
out the whole money for for doing that
so there's a huge amount of pluses and
minuses in there and i think we but i
think we should be cognizant there's an
opportunity here
that um we make a firmer commitment to
looking at the alexandra theatre as a
standalone
um entertainment venue but within the
pretext of the
future high street fund spending thank
you
it's councillor liam malone now please
um thank you chair may i commend you on
your chairmanship so far i'm enjoying it
very much
um
first of all uh clarification from
from councillor dawes uh
paul ward had walked over to me and told
me i would be committing a criminal
offence if i stayed in the room it is
very clear
the same thing was not said to
councillors hook or wrigley who
are directors of the cic a far more
influential and far more long-standing
institution than the one formed with in
council of doors last week it is
application of laws according to who you
want to persecute and it's against the
law
now moving on
um
this is
this is all very confusing isn't it
because
i mean
all this stuff about
talking to
interested parties there are 45
interested parties that approached you
a long time ago and and
none of them have been consulted with
they've all been ignored i mean
when this was first presented to us um
we were told that you know we've got to
accept it or we lose the money you know
it couldn't be re-looked at it couldn't
be re-examined would be bonkers gordon
huxwood not mine to stop for a minute
and question the course of action
uh you know that was the gun you put to
everyone's head when this was taken and
now according to action points one two
and three it's suddenly possible to seek
additional advice seek the gov ask the
government for more time seek a variance
on the proposal all things that were
simply unconscionable to this council
when we begged it to reconsider now um
can we just face up to what's really
happening here um
before we blunder into the next
unplanned adventure because this the
whole town hated your plan
last night some of the most esteemed
academic minds got together to ask how
the hell such thing even got sanctioned
and when an institution like austin's
department still has a window display
mourning the culture and the creative
opportunities for children you plan to
take away you know you're playing for
the wrong team
and your artist impression of the cinema
in the local press just released a gazer
of derision
the noise is now so loud i expect that
even mr conic who likes to govern this
district with his fingers in his ears
must have heard it by now
let's look at the timing of this there's
nothing in this motion about
uh maintaining the wall there's nothing
in this motion that
that sets aside for good the the
disastrous plan that you came up with
and and let's look at the timing of it
the people will go away and consider and
reconvene conveniently just after the
election
so you can kick this into the long grass
because you know it's really really
unpopular and then you're going to come
back and say oh we couldn't come up with
a better plan we'll revert to what we
were doing before it's just cynicism
so that you can go out and do three
minutes of litter picking with your coat
hanger smiles and expect to get four
more years of this nonsense that's what
is behind this in terms of culture
in terms of culture you you
you're putting a fig leaf of 300 000
pounds of culture on this um can some of
that money go into some sort of course
so that you guys can can learn what that
actually means
a a culture is a way in which a group of
people express themselves they express
themselves very clearly here in letters
petitions protests processions songs a
huge outpouring of culture which you uh
completely ignored you ignored all of it
the only culture you've engendered in
this district is one of anger and
distrust
so this is just
this is just insane
councillor goodman bradbury was at the
meeting last night
and people were talking about her
without realizing she was there and when
she did speak she admitted that her
position as champion of culture was only
a badge it wasn't actually something
that you actually did anything with
and she hasn't answered questions on
culture from anyone who has emailed her
so can we start with taking that badge
off her because it's not doing very much
is it
it's a complete waste of time
counselor conned is the least cultural
man who has ever lived not my words
gordon hook's words he said them to us
in a meeting with nsn i'm betraying her
confidence but i don't care at this
point it's gone too far
you don't know what you're doing with
culture this idea about
getting street performers that's just
completely back to front i i've been a
street performer for years we turn up
where there's people where there's life
where there's money create these things
and you'll have street performers it
works that way round i've never heard of
a council paying for street performers
and expecting that to you know engender
a rich civic life that is like spending
300 000 pounds on wasps and expecting
them to attract a picnic it's just
bonkers
you don't know what you're doing and i
think that this is just a cynical plan
to kick the whole thing into the long
grass until you've got the
election out the way and then you're
going to carry on ignoring the entire
population just as you have been up to
now
sorry before i go back to councillor
patch and councillor bulovan i want to
know whether there's any other members
that wish to speak
uh on this issue uh
right well
before i come to you alan if i may
i i think the best way forward to this
as chairman is to take each of these uh
items one to six in their uh
in their separate words to see what we
can get out of this
to get past today so that's where i'm
taking this as chairman in a minute
[Music]
counselor clinic can help me to do it i
can help you uh the merchant was devised
as an entity yes
and in his entity so i would resist uh
taking it uh point by point uh because i
think you know members see it in this
entirety uh and i think it's very
i wasn't looking to throw out any of the
motion as chairman i was wanting to hear
a little bit more information about each
item if it's possible because it also
says one two and three which counselor
mike hawking was was was alluded to were
quite acceptable and i'm being the
consensus is it appears to be going that
way and it it also says and also too and
and we can take four five and six and
see whether you can give it some
assurances on what you can do
from members
comments to date that's all i'm seeking
for you to do to try and get it through
but first of all we'll go back to
counselor patch and counselor bulletin
so i think there's a few a few areas
that councillor conic set out at the
beginning that neil blaney set out and
there seems to be some confusion in the
chamber
over time scales and funding
i think neil set out that we're trying
to achieve a time scale that means we
have to review the business case and
submit it to government
in december
and i expect uh those approvals
hopefully six weeks after that because
currently the team that are looking at
it are also dealing with uk shared
prosperity funding leveling up funding
bids as well
so
in terms of the risk i think council
iconic did set out that there is a risk
to doing this that we might not get the
funding so it might not be achievable
by march 2024 in terms of the spend so
there is there is a risk there um which
which you know councillors have i think
not fully appreciated in terms of this
doesn't guarantee us the other bit is
obviously you wish to state what you
want us to do and we will follow that
and council economics set out that there
may be costs involved in doing the work
necessary for that around the business
case following the green book approach
to this and the
change requests
what that doesn't guarantee is that
future high street fund accepts what you
want so we still have the risk of the
future high street fund accepting it and
i'm sorry i don't agree with council
apaches view that this can be done very
quickly this is a process that took us
many months to do it was a far more
complex business case when we had the
whole range of projects because that
took into account um at the time decking
of a flat car park
the the improvements to queen street the
the um differences and changes to the
market hall and the new cinema so there
is a huge amount of work to be done and
we are at risk of you know if we go with
your proposals here which is totally up
to you if you wish to support those we
will work to do that i cannot give you
the guarantee and i think neil in terms
of the project in the project offices
that's where we are isn't it and in
terms of martin for the section 151
officer you haven't got the financial
guarantee that you will get all of your
9.2 million pounds and you will spend it
as you wish to spend it so so
i think
yeah council comic was clear about that
at the beginning i think he sent that
out i think neil set that out
hopefully unless sorry i'll invite
either martin or neil to to to clarify
anything that i may have misread myself
thank you managing director right we've
gone back to the
the questions that councillor patch had
his hand up to speak for a second time
and so did councillor bullard so could
we hear from them thank you chair um i'd
just like to reassure mr cheers i don't
take any sense of self-esteem from
whether he agrees with me on anything or
not
i'd just like to say i've had a look at
this motion
um and i can't see anything in there at
all unless i'm missing something about
taking the alexandra out of the future
high streets funding now so unless
councillor corner is proposing an
amendment to his motion it seems to me
that he's asking us to vote for
something and then deliver something
totally different so i i would if
there's to be an amendment i would like
to
propose an amendment that on
item six in that list to consider fresh
options for the alexandra cinema theater
building
especially including the retention of
the alexandra within the future high
street funding project
but retaining the wall
i'm not sure if anybody would second
that
amendment in the second
patch
and
linda petering
right
uh now could we uh have the next speaker
which is councillor bullovans
risk of losing 9.2 million investment in
the centre of the town
and newton naval is a town that needs
that investment
i'm happy with the
suggestions that the leader is making in
terms of being able to look at some
ideas
but whatever we do what we don't want is
a pyrrhic victory
which says on one hand we want to do
something and then find we don't have
the resources and finance given to us to
be able to do it
so
what i'm very happy to support the ideas
that uh council connect is coming
forward with and i think they're good
ideas to see what can be delivered
without jeopardizing that investment in
newton abbot it's something i think if
it's all possible we should do
can i have that assurance from cancer
colonet that decisions that we make
today
minimize
any dangers or risks to the funding of
9.2 million because newton albert and
the people of newton albert
do need that investment to take place
thank you
i'm going to come back to you to counsel
connor on
that now
uh it seems to be hinging around
um
item number six in of this motion
doesn't it which is another the
thing the amendment proposed surround
six
so i don't know whether councillor conic
can give us any assurances about the
wall in
six i mean six is to consider refresh
the options for the alexander cinema
theater building the cost of living
crisis and expressed expected national
economic situation are such that the
council believes these established and
compelling case for review are set out
above so it's over to ellen to
see
thank
what
thank you chairman um what i've tried to
set out in six is embrace
the
i think mood of members that they would
like to see the alexandra building
retained with the wall in place
and then not to constrain the ability of
officers to negotiate the best we can in
terms of speaking to future high street
fund
and ideally
we'll be able to do the alex as part of
it but let's suppose governments say no
that's not possible or whatever
whatever the issues are around that
because we now wanted to be a cultural
center i was trying to identify the
council that the way forward would most
likely be that the alexander is taken
out of the future i street fund and then
becomes a council project very much to
be delivered the time scale i indicated
and i think i was very clear that it was
my personal view
was around giving groups
who may have an interest the opportunity
to consider their proposals and come to
council
in terms of councillor patch's amendment
i would resist it because i think it
constrains the option
in terms of
council malone's commentary uh i quite
like the joke that he told uh in
relation to gold nook and what he said
about me i think i told gordon that in
the first place um
the the essence of it is
on the one hand council malone has
criticized the council for apparently
not listening
when it comes to council and says we
think there may be a way forward
slightly different but there's a way
forward he criticizes the council for
listening
um
and and and in essence chairman um
you know i think council malone has
particular gifts and talents um and as
he's described them as a street
performer not necessarily a council
performer what i'm seeking to do is
bring around a motion which tries to
serve
newton and the wider district that
delivers the cinema that delivers the
market hall in a different way
to that originally perceived because we
put the eatery in
and gives the community the scope to
deliver the cultural arts center based
on the alexandria which is what many
people have wanted
and there is an opportunity through this
motion as set out chairman but i think
if we start to amend it with more
detailed approaches
the risk is hands will be tied and then
i really do think we run the risk of
snatching defeat from what could be a
very good community victory thank you
chairman
uh who was next to speak it was
councillor mcgregor then councillor mike
hawking
thank you again chair
um
i just wanted to come back on a point
that um council cox raised in in terms
of the the community benefits uh society
surely they would be looking to take on
the alexandra theatre after the work had
been done rather than prior to the work
being done and therefore any grants that
they would get would be for delivery of
of the the benefit to the the the
local community um in terms of the um
time scales i mean th this is really
quite the important thing here um the
managing director kindly uh elucidated
on the on the uh need to ensure that we
get value for money and this is this is
crux the crux of the matter uh council
bulletin's had you know it's a risk of
losing 9.2 million i think the total
spend is somewhere in the region of 13
million including devon county councils
um input into changes in queen street
and amongst other things so it's quite
significant about money we need to be
cognizant that newton abbott needs this
money spent but we need to make sure
it's spent in exactly the right way and
i think councillor patch has made a good
amendment suggestion
on the basis that let's look at an
option to take at the alexandra theatre
out of the future high street fund
it's a tiny element a tiny element of
the total delivery of the future high
street fund
therefore the rest of it
is still transformative in terms of
newton abbot
and that is the key word when it comes
to the future high street fund and we
can demonstrate that it's still
transformative based on taking the
alexander theatre out i don't see there
being a problem with the government
unless they're looking to cut costs
as usual thank you
do you want to come back on that alan
chairman um
i think i said all i need to say about
the motion i think it gives our officers
the widest scope
ideally it will stay within the future
issue fund but let's suppose let's
suppose it wasn't possible to do that i
tried to illustrate that the council
could deal with the alex outside of the
future least favorite option but an
option so i'm trying to give scope and
flexibility to the officers to bring
back and as we say in one bring back a
detailed report to council uh you know
in terms of uh what what it is possible
now there's a bit of time when that
conversation needs to be had so i really
don't want to tie the hands
of the officers
i can see where it's coming from and but
there is an amendment put up by
councillor patch and
council seconded by council
okay right now who else was speaking
counselor mike hawking wasn't it next
thank you
thank you chair for letting me come back
um
just really one sort of thing i've been
listening to what
the leader has been saying and and he's
assuring me to a certain extent that
he is willing to listen to
the group that's already
put plans forward and other groups that
may or may not come forward or it could
be a combination of all of them
but i am concerned that um that this
that the alexander comes out of the
high street fund bed
it is this the alexander the market hall
and the new cinema is all one
one unit if you like one idea
and it all depends on each other
being done correctly
the
unfortunately there's been a plan
application coming for the theater
that could or may not
affect what happens at the alexander
it could or may not affect what happens
at the market hall it depends on what
uh it happens that when that
unit comes or when our application comes
to comes the committee
but we need to be very careful that
i am wondering whether things have come
forward out of zinc if you like
because i was under the impression that
it was the market hall and alexander
theater would come before the cinema and
then the cinema would fall in in with
that
it does worry me uh and i think we need
to be very conscious of the fact
that one
one piece coming out of the sink
could actually affect the whole lot so
in fact you may not get
what you think you're going to get
if one part of it
um is a plot is
gets
gets a planning application that it
thinks is going to get i've got to be
very careful because i may be on that
planning committee when it comes when it
comes to
when it comes forward
i may not hopefully i'll leave it to
somebody else to make decisions
but
from my point of view i think what the
leader has been saying and i'm assuming
he is talking for this council and the
officers within it
as such he should
um that
at this stands at the moment i am happy
to support this motion
although as i say the caviar is that i
would like to see
it treated as one
rather than trying to pull out and i
understand what he's saying but i don't
i wouldn't like to see the alexander
being pulled out and saying oh that's
something different because what happens
in the other two parts of the equation
may well affect what happens to that and
that building so
i'll leave it there counselor colin
wants to come back and comment on that
if i may i think kazakh makes some
really good points and i'm going to try
and deal with them uh as i remember them
um there may be a planning application
for the theater from a third party group
but of course they don't own the theater
uh and you know people can put in
planning applications on on land and
buildings they don't own that would have
to be dealt with by the council in its
proper processes if an application were
received
in relation to um
council hawking's point in
what order uh my recollection is that it
was always the intention to proceed with
the cinema first because once the new
cinema was in place that's actually what
allowed uh the market hall and the alex
to be processed so cinema first alex
market hall uh next
uh
if this motion is supported i think it
supports
what council hawking is indicating um in
that
there's a separate consideration around
a cinema no pretermination from any
member wanted there
uh
the market hall there's a bit of work if
member support is a bit of work to look
at how we do that
and then i'm
fully committed
to the alex as part of newton abbott's
regeneration we just look at it in a
different way
so that it gives those group or a group
or those groups that may have an
interest in it time to time to fully
develop their plans and proposals for
council to see the proper business cases
and to make that consideration so i
think i can provide the reassurance that
council hocking is seeking
what i think he was maybe
may have been concerned about that was
that the council processed with a cinema
process with the market hall and then
didn't worry about the alex that is
absolutely not the intention because the
whole bit is around the regeneration of
newton abbott and increasing football so
i i hope i've reassured councillor
hocking on that
point thank you
and given what um
councillor connor has just said
um
are we heading towards do do councillor
patch and councillor bradford
uh want
to withdraw their uh amendment or do
they wish to proceed with
it i would like to first give assurance
i would like to first give assurance
that i was not um
certainly the intention of the proposed
amendment was not to constrain officers
or constrain debate i was just talking
about giving particular consideration to
one option and i thought i would still
like to put that amendment i'd just like
to point out that i've seen a fellow
councillor raising her hand a couple of
times i'm not sure whether councillor
cook wants to speak
no um
no i didn't call you
members saw your hand waving and
wondered whether you wanted to speak
yes
well i i i came here actually
at the beginning of the second world war
when i was seven
and the only place i used to go shopping
to was market walk
now i grew up in
newton abbott and roundabout and i
always went there and i think that the
market walk is the most essential place
in newton
it's if you come by car you have to you
go in a car park you come to market walk
if you come on the bus you get off the
bus wherever the bus stop is and you
come to market walk and i think it would
be absolutely fatal to interfere with
market walk
by all means uh
having cinema i have another cinema
because i'm great in favor of that have
a theater that would be even better to
have a reasonably priced theater for
people to go to because it's near a bus
stop and that means that people can go
to the theater and not use their motor
car they can come out of the theater and
go home on the bus it's good for the
environment but i do think that market
walk should be preserved it's the one
thing we've got left
i feel very strongly about that thank
you very much
thank you councillor cook
the question
shall i
phrase my amendments yes please okay
what i propose is um adding on to that
first line of item six so
after alexandra cinema theater building
with particular consideration given to
the jeremy nukem plan within the future
high street funding
and while retaining the rear alexandra
theater wall
so i'm talking about particular concern
i'm not about constraining options and
think this has got to be looked at or
ruling certain things out i'm just
talking about particular consideration
being given to a project that has had a
lot of input a lot of skilled input
technical input and a lot of thought
given to the business plan behind that
rather than particular consideration to
chucking it out or maybe opening up to
see who else wants to stick there to
pendlethworth in when we've had people
knocking on the door for the best part
of a year or more
trying to put forward viable plans
second it's still by councillor bradford
is that all right or are you speaking
thank you
yes um i i
wanted to make it clear why i was
particularly seconding that amendment is
because there was nothing in the motion
about the wall
and
i i just wanted it
made clear that the wall is not going to
be taken down
and the theater is not going to be
messed about with like that
right i think it's time to go to vote on
the amendment um
is that right correct
that's correct you're right
carry on councillor miller yeah i just
want to say what i i support this
amendment because i
the argument against it is going to be
oh it's going to take all this time it's
going to it's going to put the future
high street fund off it's we're going to
lose the money
um
i just want to say i i sincerely believe
the absolute opposite of that is true
if you go ahead with the plans as they
were originally written
the the resistance is going to be
enormous there are 45 cultural
institutions that that are backing the
cbs on this
there is the the theatre's trust of
expressed willingness to take this to
court it is going to be fought and
fought and fought if you try and take
that wall down
i i think it would be better
for everyone
uh if we set in stone now that that wall
is staying where it is
and then the resistance will
be i don't know if it will die away
entirely
but
it will become manageable and and and
and you can start out afresh
because
without that set in stone
uh
you're not going to get anywhere your
original plans are not going to get
passed i don't believe
uh
the the the the the legal resistance is
just going to be too big thank you
so is your amendment then to consider
one to five as being okay and uh you're
the amendment is voting uh you've
altered six in effect i'm not i'm not
making an amendment i'm merely speaking
yeah i'm trying to find out from from
council compassion councillor bradford
that yeah i would say also to scratch
the um the second line under six and the
line over the um following page because
that doesn't really add to anything it's
just a justification of fig leaf for the
u-turn
right let's uh i'll take you out in a
second allen councillor
david cox got his hand out i totally
disagree with uh councillor connor i
think it should be taken out i'm happy
with the wall bit ben we shouldn't be
looking we should be looking at that as
seeing the alexander building as a
charitable uh institution
it's it's a charity it's a it's a
non-exempt it's exactly an exempt
charity the sea the uh the society
if we were in danger of unforeseen
consequences what if winners jim wants
to bid for it if it's within the
business side we've got to take the
bigot the highest bidder so i think it
should be removed out and put into the
charitable and deemed to be a charitable
sector it means we can reduce the the
amount of we require for the lease they
will be exempt from business rates
because of their their charitable status
i think we're in very great danger of
having an unforeseen consequence of
losing the alexander building under
competition rules by taking out of the
future high streets uh
money we are actually saving it better
better chance of being being done as a
charitable organization than as a than
as a business so i think i think where
there's real dangers in pursuing this
amendment because you could lose you
could lose the alexandria building the
managing director wants to come back uh
on an issue yes sorry can i just have
clarity about the proposed amendment uh
and the relationship with the jeremy
newcomb plans
because
you know we need clarity that the
proposed jeremy newcomb plans has an
impact on the plans for the cinema
building um because the cinema and the
walkway to the side of it the proposed
extension to the right-hand side of the
doorway uh a glaze extension would be
into the area which was currently
proposed on the plan submitted for the
cinema as a walkway through into the
market walk area so
can i just take clarity that you're
still suggesting that you retain the
german newcomb plans that were submitted
earlier in the year
i said not submitted because they
weren't submitted for planning but the
plans that were proposed by the group
to the
i stand by the world as my amendment set
out which talks about giving particular
consideration to the um jeremy nukem
plan
within the future high street funding
while retaining the alexandra rear wall
i do note that doesn't give the cast
iron satisfaction of um agreement that
that war won't come down as councillor
malone has stated
but i feel that um without constraining
in the way forward i i guess my wording
was as strong as i felt it would be
i'm sensible to put the issue
counselor sally morgan's caught my eye
before i come to counselor
i would find it really hard to support
the amendment without all the
information in front of me i haven't
seen jeremy newcomb's plans in detail so
i don't know what i'm voting on so i'm
afraid i can't support this amendment
let's do it through the chair counselor
thank you chairman um
in my
introduction to the motion
i said these words and i'll just recap
them subject to a further report setting
options for the alex i believe it would
be possible to focus on the market hall
as the market and the planned eatery
this would enable the wall between the
alex and the market hall to remain i
have signaled as well and as loudly i
can the intention would be to retain the
alex as an arts and cultural center
we've listened
in that regard i resist the amendment
because it too closely defines then
the very thing colleagues have said look
the council wasn't listening it says we
must we must give special
considerational consideration to one
particular plan
actually what the council
may want to do
if it supports this motion is
that the alex is a separate and distinct
unit
that it wants to be an arts and cultural
center and it wants to invite the best
bids and give the community
organizations groups the range of them
not just one that might have been set up
recently or one that's been around for a
while but
the community to come together the
chance for the cic and others for
example to
use their role as an umbrella
organization to really bring forward the
best and to give time to it chairman
i think
that
that if
members no no i don't think if if
members
support the motion has set out
we rarely will be on the road to trying
to achieve the best of all outcomes
both for the council for newton abbott
and for the community and in particular
for those who have a particular interest
in arts and cultural endeavor and
believe that they can offer something
very special to newton abbott thank you
chairman right let's
go to the vote on the amendment now
please
uh
what do you
i should want the opportunity to sum up
before the amendments voted on
i thought you had but go on
we've had other um comments made
afterwards council college attempting to
sum up my amendment
so um i'd just like to point out that
i'm not talking about constraining
possibilities i'm talking about a
particular consideration of the jeremy
nukem plan in recognition that it
appears
that there's a good chance that it might
not be looked at might not be considered
whereas other other options in terms of
ejecting the alexandra from the future
high street funding might be
preferentially considered so i'm merely
laying down
a stake with this amendment
that we don't want to get to the stage
however many months down the line and
the jeremy nukem plan has not been
considered as part of this consultation
with the option of retaining that wall
so it's not about constraining options
it's about putting a flag up or a stake
in the ground whether you want to phrase
it that this is being considered a plan
which has had an awful lot of time put
into it and which would be um viable i'm
not saying it's the only plan i'm saying
it merits active
consideration
i think we have to now as you come back
vote on this
enough's been said we've given it a
blooming good airing in my opinion and
some very good debate has taken place i
think we vote on the amendment now
please
uh can we have a show of hands that
those that are for the amendment
nine for
those against the amendment
yeah that's lost what was the figure did
you have to get it
seventeen votes it was lost anyway to
nine votes so the amendment has failed
now we go to the substantial motion here
that is outlined before us plus
councillor collins's assurances that
he's given us
can we go to the vote please on that
point of order
we're voting on the motion or the
assurances the council has been given
well you're voting are you actually
voting on the motion at the end of the
day aren't we well thank you for that
clarity because there was some muddiness
there about whether we were voting for
the motion or voting for the motion plus
assurances which would not be on the
record
well
we're voting on the motion i'm afraid
we've heard what council of commerce has
had to say
or all right as well
it's a matter of public record it's
being recorded on the
the
video that you can all see so let's go
to the vote please on the motion those
in favor of the motion
it's pretty overwhelming but yeah those
against i'd like to see please
liam too
extensions
well the motion is carried thank you
very much i hope you enjoyed the debate
on it and we've got we finally got that
so we go on to counselors questions
which is the last item on the agenda if
you can just have 30 seconds
to get with the questions and up in
front of us that'd be great
[Music]
i'm afraid with what is on the agenda
today
well there was an explanation of that in
here which you're coming to in in the
questions from memory so uh that's
coming up so uh
can we move now to the the questions
please
we want to be away here before and get
some tea because we haven't have much in
the way of lunch so you know i'm not
gonna uh cut things short by any means
because it's not my style
and i'd like to give everybody their
chance but let's let's go into questions
and the first question is from
councillor malone about the hedgehog
business you've seen the reply uh
councillor malone haven't you to that
uh have you a supplementary question
i did and i thank the councillor for
reply
now i had intended to keep this about
hedgehogs but i saw the sentence with
regards to mitigation for house building
this is being tackled currently via
planning conditions and planning
enforcement and also via new policies in
our draft local plan and these words hit
me like a lorry on the just widened a380
because it isn't is it the biggest house
building project you have is na3 on on
which this council has consistently
kicked the can of any environmental
survey down the road i know the
developers you're selling the lantern
have asked you quite angrily as a matter
of public record on the website for a
scoping opinion on whether an
environmental impact assessment will be
necessary and last we heard that was
still unanswered can you tell it into a
question please i know there's it's
coming to a question
thank you so we have an area of
exceptionally complex diversity in a
special area of conservation on which
neither you nor any of your colleagues
or officers have done any homework that
addresses these concerns or engages on
any level with the science not on
hedgehogs not on the greater horseshoe
bat not on any of the red list species
native to warburfen that we expected to
be destroyed when this is done so my
supplementary question to ask you is why
are you talking bollocks
i've
been told that i can't really accept
that i i do understand there's a bit of
colorful language
uh okay i i think we'll just pass on on
that really i'm sorry to say it it's you
know
the wording is too prickly
i i direct you to chris versus the stage
1974 that word
right yeah
i don't know whether anybody's going to
answer that as a supplementary question
but uh
i think you'll you'll just have to dream
i think
no i'm talking about
you you can speak
i can explain why i'm not going to
answer it
yes that may be good
yeah it's a shame because i did have an
answer ready but i'm not going to answer
the question framed in that way thank
you
on to the next question
uh the next question is from
councillor
bradford isn't it here
and you've seen the the answer given
councillor bradford do you have a
supplementary question
yes i do
please go ahead
um
this is about
conservation areas windows
um bearing in mind the carbon action
plan we just voted for and we have
declared a climate emergency
the answer to my question pointed me
towards the historic england website
historic england in its conservation
area overview is pretty clear that each
local authority must decide for itself
which which normally permitted
development rights may be excised
from the general permitted development
order 2015 of town and country planning
it is therefore up to this
administration to define define what
gives an area a special character
not any national statute
the uk's 10 000
conservation area range from medieval
streets to apartment blocks it is simply
not true to suggest that they are
governed by some immutable laws that
team bridge has to slavishly obey
can you explain to us how you square the
need for zero carbon for non-leaky
housing for insulated dwellings for
affordable heating for the district's
poorer residents
with the hundreds of houses in this
district with rotting slash windows that
cannot be economically or usefully
repaired
thank you very much i have a certain
amount of sympathy with that question
living in an old grade two listed
building with sort of stash windows so
hopefully gary taylor councillor garrity
will provide an answer to this question
of whether there's there's any light at
the end of the tunnel
thank you chair and thank you for the
supplementary question councillor
bradford um as you've seen in the
response it's not something that we can
compromise on
within conservation areas or with regard
to listed buildings i own an old house
myself and i've just replaced
some
bad plastic windows with small plastic
windows despite it being 100 years old
and i'm grateful that i don't live in a
conservation area from that point of
view
it does seem to me that legislation
really should be moving towards
a balance in sustainability
in terms of
the plastic windows they are not at all
environmentally
friendly they do when they do need
replacing we have to consider how
they're disposed of and yes it is much
more expensive to to fit um
tim timber windows uh and when uh
budgets don't allow um you know it it
does mean that you're often put in a
position where you have to retain those
windows or to repair them so i can or i
can only offer my sympathy but i can't
offer a solution thank you
thank you very much for that answer now
we go into councillor mcgregor's uh
question and the response
that was given to him
uh cap
the chair's not here yeah um
so councilman mcgregor do you have a
supplementary question i do
um however um
would it be possible for that um
supplementary to be carried over to when
the chair is here to answer the
supplementary questions
well that absorbs me of a bit of
responsibility so i should say certainly
yes can you check with democratic
services because they have a tendency to
disallow questions that have been asked
already are you
are you able to answer that in
democratic services
defer it to the chairman's back in place
[Music]
yes thank you i think so
next one's for me as well i think so
might as well just uh
leave it here um
thank you very much for the response uh
council wrigley um
it is slightly disappointing because the
discussions uh about naming the the
building happened long before the work
actually commenced on both sides
and it is disappointing that we didn't
as a council make an opportu or take an
opportunity to
inject a little bit of diversity and
inclusion into the naming of the the two
properties at drake road and east street
um and whilst they recognize that you do
say that time constraints
you know and and it's a well house to
reflect the historic well
um perhaps there was an opportunity to
recognize
um
you know
b.a.m.e um
you know contributors to devon
particularly not newton abbott or or um
you know the first member of the bar
who's uh
female perhaps
and i think that's an opportunity missed
um can we make sure in future that we do
make every attempt to be a bit more
inclusive and diverse
so really is going to answer your
supplementary i agree i'd welcome a
standing list of names that we can
select from in future
thank you very much
our microphone's not on councillor on to
your next question please
thank you chair
um uh
thank you for your response uh gary it
was just really to ask about a
commitment i don't think really that's
the the the um
it was just really to ask whether or not
the executive will maintain its
commitment to the teen estuary trail
it's a simple yes or no answer
thank you very much
i can confirm
that we do remain entirely committed to
the teen estuary trail i'd love to see
it built as soon as possible
there's a number of steps to go through
which is why funding hasn't
been allocated to that at this point in
time because of the end dates and the
funding
uh timeline drawdowns so yes is the
answer
wherever are we next with this next
question
uh
it's councilman mcgregor again surprise
no um
no i don't have a response i think from
the perspective of the previous uh
answer to my supplementary i think um
that's been answered as well
so where are we now over the page uh no
it's a question for me i think right
okay
um
which which where are we in the in it
i'm almost losing it
we're there are we exactly right
yeah
this is the question from you last
october november 2021 right group and
the group count why was it disabled yes
uh who took this decision you've got a
response from uh the leader and uh
no i i don't think there's a
supplementary other than just a note
that the uh coalition clearly were
consulted but nobody else
right okay um the next question um
i note that the leader says that there
were no complaints but um
can he detail how how in-depth his
investigation of the lack of complaints
was
please
i can't detail how in-depth the lack of
complaints was because if there were no
complaints they can't investigate them
yeah well
okay um
well my supplementary question to three
why was this not announced formally with
an explanation um
and when will it be stored i'll do that
as one one of the reasons why it
if there were no complaints there was no
complaints either way is effectively
what you're saying
um so from my perspective when will it
be
i restored councilman mcgregor said
there have been a lack of complaints and
why haven't they been investigated uh
and i was saying you can't investigate
complaints you haven't received um so
so i'm now i'm now moving on to the next
point which is um y wasn't announced
formally and it was and council
mcgregor's referred to the members
newsletter number 113 of the 9th of
december
point of order chair
go for it then point of order if we're
going to get answers we want accurate
answers the question was
why wasn't it announced in advance of
the change the change happened on the
six
the announcement came out on the ninth
in the members newsletter i emailed the
manager director on the ninth and asked
him why it hadn't been announced in
advance of the actual thing i haven't
actually had a response to that
surprisingly enough
um but i'm sure you know i'm not i'm not
um upset with the managing director for
that he's got a very full plate i do
understand that and it did come out in
the members newsletter but let's stop
with the sophistry and answer the
questions accurately let's not stop
answering questions you think have been
answered and answer the question
chairman i can't help if councillor
mcgregor misspoke if i misheard the
question
but i provided the answers of the
question i understood with regard to
the timing between
the group mail being turned off and the
members newsletter as all members will
know the members newsletter is the
primary source of information for which
the council seeks weekly uh to update
and inform councillors and i understand
that was the next available newsletter
for members to receive it thank you the
question
well that's the answer we've got i'm
afraid
okay well that will speak up to you
uh
okay the next one is from
uh
counselor
okay so he's not able to ask a
supplementary okay
so it's now question from councillor
malone
thank you once again um
yeah thank you uh portfolio holder gary
for your answer
oh sorry it was you uh sorry i thought
it came from gary
housing fair enough um
can we use proper pronouns counselor so
and so rather than first names because
people may be listening in and they
don't know who they are
yes good point
thank you councillor sylvia
uh
so i suppose my supplementary is um i
don't know why is your tone one of
sorrow and empathy nice though that is
rather than
i don't know
anger and admonition because i i think
one thing you could do if you were so
minded is to stand up and say on behalf
of these people who've lost thousands of
pounds who now find themselves without
an address who's who's who have to find
in some cases new skills for their kids
you know it isn't fair
because they might not then feel so
alone in this struggle and you could say
in public and on record to belfield
homes and to complete estate agents and
to anyone else involved you know we
can't force you to do this or that or
the other but
but we do simply expect you and we ask
of you to do better by the people we
serve in the community where you do
business so as a supplementary i would
ask you know except you have limited
powers over developers and businesses
but why do we have to tiptoe around them
so much why are we so terrified of
offending them to the point i might add
of persecuting our own members when we
dare to criticize them
martin councillor martin wrigley
will answer the supplementary as best he
can
i'm certainly not afraid of them i'm
certainly happy to stand up to them i
didn't have the details of the
particular cases that you're talking
about i'm happy to go and um shout at
them although it will do no good
whatsoever but i'm happy to do that and
i will always defend residents
uh next question from councillor um
bradford
okay and you've seen the response uh
here
from
um
could we have you got a supplementary on
that one
no thank you chair i don't have a
supplementary question at this time
thank you for telling us that um
the next question is from councillor
mcgregor
do you have a supplementary
uh thank you uh
chair on the first one uh
no
and the second one
um
yes um
the second one was attended for
self-build homes aimed at maximizing the
number to be built the response i
received said that appendix 4 of the
committee report included a number of
homes to be built well actually it
didn't include the number it included a
range of numbers of houses to be built
and at the time of the
the discussion when it came to the
executive i was keen that we maximized
the number of houses built because some
of these were to be social
housing
and it was just to really establish
whether or not we were pushing for
maximizing the number to be built
so if we could get clarity on maximizing
the number rather than going for the
lowest because the report that came
reduced the minimum from 15 to 10
which gives us a
a general sense of direction
in in terms of the development and the
plans for it and i would like the
commitment to be that we are going for a
higher number than 10
as many as 20 if possible
counselor gary taylor is going to
respond
thank you thank you very much for the
question certainly it would be our our
wish that as
many uh come forward as possible um this
application is 1702
to 1 1702166
which was approved on the uh 21st of
june 2019
and it was for up to 20 custom build
dwellings
it's a particularly uh
prominent site uh it's
it's got a design code within the within
the list of documents that are provided
there are a lot of
things that that
would make it difficult to maintain the
number of homes that we'd
originally wished to have on the site
there are backed uh corridors uh there
are a lot of uh conditions required with
regard to how the appearance of the of
the buildings which are to be taken as a
as a rural farmstead so i'm sure that
the designers
the of this the scheme will want to take
all of the everything into account and
to maximize the number of homes that are
built on the site the more homes they
can build on the site the more profit
they're likely to make but at the end of
the day
we will have to see how it how it all
pans out in the in the mix of planning
considerations thank you thank you
the question is from councillor patch
do you have a supplementary question
thank you chair um
i do i just say i'm a little
disappointed um to be only having a
supplementary question to one of the
four questions i submitted and um being
referred to freedom of information
requests for other questions including
the 20 000 pound question as to what
happened to um account for the 20 000
pounds of lost taxpayers money regarding
some sort of um sort of failure of the
planning department here
but still that that question is
available elsewhere um
so with regard to this um question i'd
like to post supplementary questions for
parts a and part c of my question
part a
um and and i know this is actually a
request from the vice chair yourself um
so
perhaps and i do hesitate in in that
case posing this question but i'd like
to know why the response
misrepresents the constitution of this
council in saying that there was a 5 pm
deadline for the substitution of um
rather for the registering of support
for my motions
and looking at 4.7.3 questions requiring
notice
actually does suggest a 5 p.m or would
not suggest it points out at 5 pm
deadline for the reception of those
questions whereas 4.9 motions on notice
gives no such deadline it does not
mention a 5 pm deadline it talks about
the days um and and indeed past practice
for submission of motions support has
been allowed up until the close of that
day so i'm a little bemused as to why um
that this constitution has been
misrepresented
well you've seen the answers given i'm
in divide only in the vice chair you've
made your point and i think that's the
answer to the question well i made my
question
i've received um some words i haven't
received an answer to the question but i
will move on chair um part c
um
and um
this again relates to the rejection of
my motions of no confidence in the
leader of the council and the chair of
the standards committee
from one one fellow scholar in terms of
discourse analysis to to another i'd
like to ask given that they were
rejected for inappropriate and
inflammatory language
can you please share with me
what definition of inflammatory you're
using and which language in each of my
emotions
you consider inflammatory because i i
might consider an accusation of
inflammatory language to be defamatory
language
well we we saw what you submitted and
that was the ruling at the end of the
day
so
i think it's something that you're just
gonna have to beg to differ with um
you think differently other people think
differently and you know i think we have
to to
park it there i'm afraid okay i do know
i did look up the definition of
inflammatory and they seem to be talking
about inciting anger
i think it's no bad thing when people do
get angry about certain things happening
um and i'd like to sort of end by
briefly quoting from the character from
network albert finney character i
believe who said um i quote i'm mad as
hell and i'm not going to take it
anymore
that really concludes the meeting thank
you everybody for your your diligence
and and your input today we've finally
closed the meeting at 2 47 thank you all
for attending and hearing everybody and
we can go home now thank you so much
meeting closed
you